Mohamedsalem is 33. And his parents want him to call his cousins on the phone. He doesn't want to. He doesn't like to. And I have to say, I'm with him. He's got a really good excuse.
Mohamedsalem 今年33岁。他的父母希望他给表亲们打个电话，但他不想，他不喜欢这样做。我不得不说，我支持他。他有一个非常正当的理由。
[SIGHS] I just grew up never knowing them. For me, I need to spend time with them to start to be attached to them.
[叹气] 我长这么大，从来没见过他们。对我来说，我需要花时间和他们相处，才能开始对他们产生感情。
No, I understand. They're like strangers to you.
不，我理解。对你来说，他们就像陌生人一样。
Yes, exactly.
是的，正是如此。
He never got to know any of his relatives because Morocco built a wall 1,700 miles long across the desert. It's actually several walls of piled up sand, plus ditches in between the walls, plus barbed wire, plus, reportedly, seven million landmines, plus 120,000 soldiers separating the rest of his family, who were in Western Sahara, from the place where Mohamedsalem was born and still lives today, a massive refugee settlement with an estimated 165,000 people in it on the other side of the wall. So he has all these cousins from eight aunts and uncles. And--
他从来没有机会去了解他的任何亲戚，因为摩洛哥在沙漠中修建了一道1700英里长的墙。实际上，它是几道由沙堆垒成的墙，墙之间还有沟渠、铁丝网，据报道还有七百万颗地雷，以及12万名士兵，将他在西撒哈拉的其余家人与Mohamedsalem出生并至今居住的地方隔离开来。那是一个巨大的难民营，住着大约16.5万人，就在墙的另一边。所以他有来自八位叔伯姨妈的很多表亲。而且——
I would never met them. There is nothing in common. We haven't shared anything. I know their names, and I know I have a relative. But--
我永远也不会见到他们。我们之间没有什么共同点。我们没有任何共同经历。我知道他们的名字，也知道我有这样一位亲戚。但是——
That must be so frustrating for your parents.
这对你的父母来说一定很沮丧。
[LAUGHS] All the time they try to get me to call them and talk to them, but what should we talk about? And what do we have in common that we can talk about if we finish the initial greeting? And I feel guilty about it and bad about it, but it's just I don't know what to do about it.
[笑] 他们总是试图让我给他们打电话，和他们聊天，但我们能聊些什么呢？如果寒暄完了，我们还有什么共同话题可以聊？对此我感到内疚，也感觉很糟糕，但我真的不知道该怎么办。
Not that his parents get this.
并不是说他的父母理解这一点。
They are mad. But part of the blame belongs to them, to the fact that the occupation and the family separation. And I shouldn't be totally the one to take all the responsibility for everything.
他们很生气。但部分责任在于他们，在于占领和家庭分离的事实。我不应该独自承担所有的责任。
Oh, I see. You're saying, don't blame me. There's an entire international situation here. I am not personally to blame for this.
哦，我明白了。你是说，别怪我。这整个情况是国际性的。我不应该为此承担个人责任。
Yeah, yeah. I didn't choose to leave away from them. And if I have the chance, I would love to be with them and get to know them.
是啊，是啊。我并没有选择远离他们。如果我有机会，我非常希望能和他们在一起，去了解他们。
But the wall between the refugee camp where he's lived his life and the area where his family's from, where he says they belong, that wall is the central fact of his life, the rock on which everything else is built. If the wall weren't there, instead of his current life, where he spends his days doing politics, trying to draw the world's attention to the situation his people are in--
但是他生活了一辈子的难民营和他家人来自的地方之间那堵墙——也就是他认为他们所属的地方——那堵墙是他生活的核心事实，是他人生一切建立其上的基石。如果那堵墙不存在，他现在的生活就不是这样了，他也不必整天忙于政治，试图引起世界对他人民所处境地的关注——
I for sure would have nothing to do with politics. And I wish I had the option and the choice to care about silly things like the rest of the people. I love swimming. And I have done it just like three or four times, once when I was a child.
我肯定不会去碰政治。我真希望我有权力和选择去关心像其他人一样的小事。我热爱游泳。但我只游过三四次，有一次还是在童年。
And there's no place to swim in the refugee camp.
而且难民营里没有游泳的地方。
No, no, no, no, no, no, there isn't. There isn't.
不，不，不，不，不，没有。根本没有。
There's a 1,700 mile wall between him and the ocean. When somebody builds a wall, we readjust our lives around that wall.
他和海洋之间隔着一堵1700英里的墙。当有人建起一堵墙时，我们就会围绕这堵墙调整我们的生活。
So just tell us what you're doing here.
那告诉我们你在这里做什么。
I'm just closing the main gate until tomorrow morning.
我只是在关主大门，直到明天早上。
So what's this gate made of?
那这扇门是什么做的？
I don't know.
不知道。
[BANGING]
[撞击声]
What is that? Steel?
那是什么？钢制的？
Yeah.
是的。
With big spikes on the top.
上面还有大尖刺。
In Belfast, Northern Ireland, it's been 20 years since peace was declared between Protestants and Catholics. But there are still these tall walls, some of them 50 feet high, that separate their neighborhoods with a few gates that allow traffic and pedestrians through. It's 6:30 at night, and the guard is closing the Northumberland Gate for the evening. It will reopen at 6:30 in the morning. Producer Conor Garrett talked to him.
在北爱尔兰的贝尔法斯特，新教徒和天主教徒之间宣布和平已经20年了。但这里仍然有那些高墙，有些高达50英尺，将他们的社区隔开，只有几扇门允许车辆和行人通行。现在是晚上6点半，守卫正在关闭诺森伯兰门。它要到明天早上6点半才会重新开放。制作人Conor Garrett采访了他。
They're just waving people through. You can see people are rushing before they close up for the day.
他们只是挥手让人们通过。你可以看到人们在关门前匆忙赶路。
Yeah. I could actually time them. I could actually time them.
是的。我其实可以给他们计时。我真的可以给他们计时。
You mean you can time them? You know what time they're going to come through?
你是说你能给他们计时？你知道他们什么时候会通过？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
People are so used to having the walls and so nervous about the violence that might break out if they were torn down that two decades after the conflict officially ended when there was a modest proposal not to tear the walls down but to simply replace the sheet of steel that was the gate at the Workman Avenue crossing with a gate that is steel bars that you can see through to the other side, that took 18 months to convince local residents of. Ian McLaughlin is one of the organizers who pushed for that change.
人们太习惯于这些墙的存在，也太担心如果拆除墙体可能爆发的暴力事件，以至于在冲突正式结束二十年后，当有人提出一个温和的建议——不是拆墙，而仅仅是将沃克曼大道交叉口那扇铁板门换成一种能看穿另一边的钢筋门时——竟然花了18个月才说服当地居民。Ian McLaughlin是推动这一变革的组织者之一。
It was a very long and drawn out process because you have to take into account people's fears. The vast majority of deaths which occurred during the conflict occurred where these structures were built. And the point I make is that, primarily for some of our elderly residents who live in these neighborhoods, a death of a family member that may have happened-- I don't know-- 30 or 40 years ago, it's as though it happened 30 days ago. So any conversation or any suggestion of a removal of that structure, it actually, to this day, traumatizes these families.
这是一个非常漫长且艰巨的过程，因为你必须考虑到人们的恐惧。冲突期间绝大多数的死亡事件都发生在该结构建筑的地方。我提出的观点是，主要是对于一些住在这个社区的老年居民来说，哪怕是一位家庭成员在30或40年前离世，对他们来说就像是30天前发生的一样。所以任何关于移除该结构的谈话或建议，至今仍会给这些家庭带来创伤。
I think you have to realize, in people's mindsets, if you have lived in the same neighborhood for 40 years, and every single day when you wake up, the first thing you see when you draw your blinds is this structure at the bottom of your garden or your alleyway, if you're waking up one morning and that structure's gone, how would you feel?
我认为你必须意识到人们的心态，如果你在同一个社区住了40年，每天醒来拉开百叶窗，第一眼看到的就是花园或小巷尽头的这个建筑物，如果有一天早上你醒来，那个建筑物不见了，你会作何感想？
Once a wall is up, it seems hard to tear down. And more are going up these days around the world. India's building a 2,500 mile barbed wire fence on the border with Bangladesh. Kenya's built just a few miles of what it hopes will be hundreds of miles of wall on the Somalia border. Israel had 300 miles of walls between itself and the West Bank and then added another 245 miles on the border with Egypt in 2013.
一旦墙建起来，似乎就很难拆掉。而且最近世界各地正在兴建更多的墙。印度正在孟加拉国边境建造一道2500英里的铁丝网围栏。肯尼亚在索马里边境修建了仅几英里长的一段围栏，它希望最终能延长至数百英里。以色列在自己与西岸之间修建了300英里的墙，并在2013年又在埃及边境增加了245英里。
The main reason walls are going up around the world right now is to stop unwanted immigrants. That's the reason for the wall that was just finished between Turkey and Syria, which is nearly 500 miles long. It's there to block terrorists and Syrian refugees. Journalist Maya talked to me from Kilis.
目前世界各地修建围墙的主要原因是阻止不受欢迎的移民。这就是土耳其和叙利亚之间那道刚刚完工的围墙的原因，它全长近500英里。它的存在是为了阻挡恐怖分子和叙利亚难民。记者Maya从基利斯跟我谈了这件事。
We are at the border gates. Every Syrian who you speak to who has managed to cross the wall speaks about having been shot at either with rubber bullets or with real bullets. And Syrians have been killed, yes.
我们就在边境关口。你交谈过的每一位设法越过围墙的叙利亚人都说，他们曾遭到橡胶子弹或实弹射击。是的，叙利亚人被杀害了。
Stopping immigrants, of course, is the reason for the wall that President Trump wants to build on the Mexican border, the one he shut down the government over.
当然，阻止移民也是特朗普总统想要在墨西哥边境修建围墙的原因，他甚至为此关闭了政府。
Look at all of the countries that have walls. And they work, 100%. A wall is a wall.
看看所有那些有围墙的国家。它们确实有效，百分之百有效。墙就是墙。
That was at his cabinet meeting this week. In San Diego last year, he inspected prototypes of different walls for the border.
那是他本周在内阁会议上说的话。去年在圣地亚哥，他考察了各种边境墙的原型。
The round piece that you see up here or you see more clearly back there, the larger it is, the better it is because it's very hard to get over the top. These are like professional mountain climbers. They're incredible climbers. They can't climb some of these walls. Some of them, they can. Those are the walls we're not using.
你在这里看到的圆形部分，或者你在后面看得更清楚的那个，它越大越好，因为翻过顶部非常困难。他们就像专业的登山运动员。他们是不可思议的攀爬者。他们爬不过其中一些墙。有些墙他们能爬过。那些是我们不用的墙。
Stopping immigrants is the reason that Norway just built a wall that is a measly 650 feet long at the very tippy top of Norway at the Russian border. I talked to the mayor of the town on the Norwegian side of that border, Mayor Rune Rafaelsen, of the town of Kirkenes.
阻止移民也是挪威刚刚在挪威最顶端与俄罗斯边境处修建了一道仅650英尺长的围墙的原因。我采访了该边境挪威一侧的城镇基尔克内斯的市长Rune Rafaelsen。
Can you see Russia from your house?
你能从你家看到俄罗斯吗？
Not from my house, no. But from my cabin, I can see Russia. [LAUGHS] Yeah.
从我家不行。但从我的小屋，我可以看到俄罗斯。[笑] 是的。
If I could just talk to the liberals in our audience for a second, I know when you guys think of the Scandinavian governments, they seem so competent and functional with their universal health care and their broad social safety nets. And I just want to say, perhaps it will be comforting to you to hear that this particular project was just as bumbling as anything we do here in the United States. They built their fence a full year after migrants had already stopped trying to cross that particular border, so there were no migrants to stop. They accidentally started construction too close to the Russian border, then had to tear it down and move it back a foot and a half.
如果我能对我们听众中的自由派说几句，我知道当你们想到斯堪的纳维亚政府时，由于他们全民医保和广泛的社会安全网，他们似乎非常有能力且高效。我只想说，听到这个特定的项目和我们在美国做的任何事情一样笨拙，或许会让你感到欣慰。他们在移民已经停止尝试越过那段边境整整一年后才建起了围栏，所以根本没有移民需要阻挡。他们不小心把施工地点选得太靠近俄罗斯边境，然后不得不把它拆掉，向后移动了一英尺半。
And they built their fence right next to a fence that Russia already had at the very same border, a way more effective fence that stretches 120 miles. Remember, the Norwegian fence is only 650 feet long. As the mayor pointed out, refugees will be able to simply walk around a fence that is that short. So why build it?
而且他们把围栏建在了俄罗斯在同一边境已经拥有的围栏旁边，那道围栏要有效得多，延伸了120英里。记住，挪威的围栏只有650英尺长。正如市长指出的那样，难民完全可以绕过那么短的围栏。那为什么要建它呢？
Because the government wanted to do something, to say that we are building walls up, way before it was inspired by Mr. Trump and the walls to Mexico. I don't know. So it's just a symbol. It has no effect regarding protecting Norway from refugees at all, so people are laughing about it.
因为政府想做点什么，表示我们在建墙，这在特朗普先生和墨西哥围墙的启发之前就有了。我不知道。所以这只是一个象征。它对保护挪威免受难民的影响根本没有作用，所以人们都在嘲笑它。
Wait. I still feel confused. If there's already a fence on the Russian side, why would there need to be a second fence?
等等。我还是觉得困惑。如果俄罗斯一侧已经有围栏了，为什么还需要第二道围栏？
Yeah. [CHUCKLES] I agree. You'd have to ask the recent prime minister about that. I don't understand why they have built this fence. It's very, very odd. They're very comic.
是啊。[轻笑] 我同意。你得去问问最近的首相。我不明白他们为什么要建这个围栏。这非常非常奇怪。它们非常滑稽。
A wall, apparently, just has its own gravitational pull that warps the logic of the world around it. And once the wall is up and is a fact on the landscape, it alters the human behavior on either side of it. At that point, it's like we accommodate the wall, and definitely not the other way around. We are the ivy that grows on it. It is the immovable object.
显然，一堵墙本身具有一种引力，会扭曲它周围世界的逻辑。一旦围墙建起并成为景观中的一个事实，它就会改变墙两侧的人类行为。在那一点上，就像是我们去适应墙，绝对不是反过来。我们是墙上生长的常春藤。它是不可移动的物体。
Today on our program, as our government fights over whether or not to build a big, beautiful wall that apparently Mexico is not going to pay for, we have stories about people and walls all over the globe. We hear about kids who use a border wall as a tool in their family relationships, people who devote themselves to conquering walls, and a wall that supposedly can only be seen from one side, and not the other-- no kidding.
今天我们的节目中，当我们的政府为了是否要修建一堵宏伟的、美丽的墙（显然墨西哥不会买单）而争论不休时，我们将带来世界各地关于人和墙的故事。我们将听到孩子们如何利用边境墙作为家庭关系的工具，有人致力于征服墙，以及一堵据说只能从一面看到而不能从另一面看到的墙——没开玩笑。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《这就是美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请留在这里。
Act One, "Just Another Kind Of Outdoor Game."
第一幕，“只不过是另一种户外游戏”。
So when we were looking at border walls and fences around the world, one in particular stood out to us because if there were ever a place where you think you could build a physical barrier between two places and have it work, this would be the place. The fences are around the Spanish cities of Malilla and Ceuta. Now, the interesting thing about these Spanish cities is they are actually in Africa.
所以当我们观察世界各地的边境墙和围栏时，其中一个特别引起了我们的注意，因为如果你认为在两个地方之间建立一个物理屏障并使之起作用是可能的话，那这一定就是那个地方。围栏围绕着西班牙城市梅利利亚和休达。现在，关于这些西班牙城市有趣的一点是，它们实际上位于非洲。
Right on the Northern coast of Africa, right there on the mainland, right on the edge of the water in what would otherwise be the country of Morocco, there are these two little dots, two cities that are officially part of Spain. Ceuta and Malilla are both very small. Ceuta is about seven square miles. Malilla is less than five square miles. And if you can make it into either of these cities from the rest of Africa, you're on European soil. You can try to claim asylum, or find some other way to stay and live in Europe.
就在非洲北海岸，就在大陆上，就在水边，本应属于摩洛哥这个国家，却有两个小点，两座正式属于西班牙的城市。休达和梅利利亚都很小。休达大约有7平方英里。梅利利亚不到5平方英里。如果你能从非洲其他地方进入这两个城市中的任何一个，你就踏上了欧洲的土地。你可以尝试申请庇护，或者找到其他方式留在欧洲生活。
But the Spanish government, with the assistance of the Moroccan government, has built a very impressive barrier. Around Ceuta, there are two layers of fencing almost 20 feet high with razor wire on the top. Around Malilla, there are four fences and a trench, basically a moat without water in it-- it's two meters deep-- also infrared cameras, and of course, guards.
但是西班牙政府在摩洛哥政府的协助下，建立了一个非常令人印象深刻的屏障。在休达周围，有两层近20英尺高的围栏，顶部有刀片刺网。在梅利利亚周围，有四道围栏和一条沟渠，基本上是一个没有水的护城河——有两米深——还有红外摄像头，当然，还有守卫。
And what has happened is that this has created a perverse and pretty dangerous obstacle course. Because, of course, people try to storm the barrier, sometimes in huge groups trying to get through it all at once, any way they can.
结果就是，这创造了一个反常且非常危险的障碍赛。因为当然，人们试图冲击这个屏障，有时是成群结队地试图一次性全部闯入，用尽一切办法。
[SHOUTING]
[喊叫声]
Our producer, David Kestenbaum, talked to one man who thought he could make it.
我们的制作人David Kestenbaum采访了一个认为自己能成功的人。
David is from Cameroon. And when I asked him to say his full name, just so I didn't mess it up, he gave this surprisingly long answer.
David来自喀麦隆。当我让他说出他的全名时，为了不弄错，他给出了这个出人意料的长答案。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语讲话]
I couldn't tell what was going on, because we were doing the interview through an interpreter. But it turns out he was explaining how he would introduce himself as an African.
我不知道发生了什么，因为我们是通过翻译进行采访的。但事实证明，他是在解释他作为一个非洲人会如何介绍自己。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语讲话]
The names of his grandparents, and their parents, and theirs.
他祖父母的名字，以及他们父母的名字，以此类推。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Those are the 23 generations of my grandparents, he says, 23 generations of names. And yet despite all that history, in September of 2013, David decided to leave Cameroon and try to make it to Europe. He was 25 years old. David describes the whole thing almost as if you were a kid heading out on an adventure in some old novel.
他说，那是他祖父母的23代人，23代人的名字。然而，尽管有那段历史，在2013年9月，David决定离开喀麦隆，试图进入欧洲。他当时25岁。David描述整件事时，简直就像一个孩子在某部旧小说中踏上冒险之旅一样。
Unlike a lot of people trying to get from Africa to Europe, he said he wasn't persecuted back home. He wasn't starving. He wasn't fleeing violence. He was just curious about the world and excited to see it. He wanted to live in a place with more opportunity, so he threw some stuff in a little backpack and he hit the road. He was well into his journey in Algeria when he first heard about the fences around Ceuta and Malilla.
与许多试图从非洲进入欧洲的人不同，他说他在家乡没有受到迫害。他没有挨饿。他不是在逃离暴力。他只是对世界充满好奇，并渴望看到它。他想住在一个有更多机会的地方，所以他往小背包里塞了一些东西，就上路了。当他第一次听说休达和梅利利亚周围的围栏时，他已经在阿尔及利亚的旅途中了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Because there we had internet access, and we could see how people were trying to jump this fence and all that.
因为我们在那里有网络连接，我们可以看到人们是如何试图跳过这道围栏以及诸如此类的事情。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
At the beginning, my opinion was, well, you know, I'm a pretty brave guy. And when I see something like that-- I like challenges. I thought I would do it in one try. I'm going to take it on with a lot of optimism, because that's the type of person I am.
起初，我的想法是，嗯，你知道，我是一个相当勇敢的人。当我看到那种东西时——我喜欢挑战。我想我会一次就成功。我将以极大的乐观精神去面对它，因为我就是那种人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I usually do things the first time I try them. I don't do them two or three times. So I thought this was going to be the case with this fence.
我通常第一次尝试就做成了。我不做两三次。所以我认为这道围栏也会是这种情况。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I've watched some of these videos. There are some brutal ones-- people with their hands sliced open from the razor wire, sometimes being hit by guards. But there are ones that, if you are preparing to try something like this, might give you hope.
我看过一些这样的视频。有些非常残酷——人们的手被刀片刺网割开，有时被警卫殴打。但也有些视频，如果你正准备尝试这种事情，可能会给你带来希望。
[SHOUTING]
[喊叫声]
This one starts at a tense moment. There are bunch of men sitting on top of the last of the fences. Below them is Spanish soil, but also the Spanish police. In theory, the guys should be able to drop down and apply for asylum. But there are lots of reports of Spanish border guards grabbing people, unlocking a gate in the fence, and returning them to the other side. So the men on the fence want to get down somehow, avoid the guards, and run into town.
这个视频开始于一个紧张的时刻。一群人坐在最后一道围栏的顶端。在他们下面是西班牙领土，当然还有西班牙警察。从理论上讲，这些人应该能够跳下去并申请庇护。但有很多报道称西班牙边境警卫抓住人们，解锁围栏上的一道门，将他们送回另一边。所以围栏上的人想方设法跳下来，避开警卫，跑进城里。
[SHOUTING]
[喊叫声]
Suddenly, one man drops down off the fence, then another. It's like they've got some plan. And apparently they do, because the two of them link arms. Then another guy joins them and another. They keep linking up, like it's a rugby scrum.
突然，一个人从围栏上跳了下来，接着是另一个人。就像他们有什么计划一样。显然他们确实有，因为他们俩挽起了手臂。然后又一个人加入了他们，又一个人。他们不断地连接在一起，就像橄榄球争球一样。
At this point, the police move in they're wearing vests and helmets. Some have those transparent shields you see in crowd control situations. And you can see the police are now in kind of a bind. It's going to be hard to pry these guys apart now that they've become this giant organism.
这时，警察行动起来，他们穿着背心和头盔。有些人拿着你在人群控制情况中看到的透明盾牌。你可以看到警察现在陷入了困境。一旦这些人变成了一个巨大的有机体，就很难将他们分开了。
So the police do this thing that also seems smart. They form a human ring around the men to contain them. And for a moment, it seems like a stalemate.
所以警察做了一件看起来也很聪明的事情。他们围着这些人形成了一个人墙圈以控制他们。那一刻，似乎陷入了僵局。
But then the scrum starts to rotate, which makes them harder to contain. And a gap opens up in the ring of police. Then one guy from the scrum breaks off and starts sprinting. Then another spins off, and another.
但随后争球阵型开始旋转，这使得他们更难被控制。警察圈出现了一个缺口。然后争球阵型中的一个人挣脱出来开始冲刺。接着另一个人转了出来，又一个。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
They run across this open field into town, and finally to the official immigration center where they celebrate like a team that's just captured the flag.
他们跑过这片开阔地进入城镇，最终到达官方移民中心，他们像一个刚刚夺旗的球队一样庆祝。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I don't know how many of these people were granted asylum or allowed to stay. But can I just say there is something crazy about a system where countries build super tall, multi-layer razor wire fences that you are definitely not supposed to cross. But if you do cross them, well, maybe you can stay. It's as if Spain is saying, this is who we want to immigrate-- people who are really good at climbing fences.
我不知道这些人中有多少获得了庇护或被允许留下。但我能说吗，在一个国家建立超高、多层刀片刺网围栏，明确禁止你越过，但如果你真的越过了，嗯，也许你可以留下，这样的体制本身就很疯狂。就好像西班牙在说，这就是我们要移民的人——非常擅长爬围栏的人。
David figured he had a pretty good chance of getting over the fences. He was young. He felt strong. He saw them up close soon after he got to Morocco. He made his way to this forest where he heard people camped out before attempting to cross. You could see Malilla from there, this piece of Europe surrounded by fencing.
David认为他很有希望翻过围栏。他很年轻。他感到强壮。他到摩洛哥后不久就近距离观察了它们。他前往这片森林，听说人们在尝试越境前就在这里露营。你可以从那里看到梅利利亚，这一块被围栏环绕的欧洲领土。
They said to me, look, over there. That's Malilla.
他们对我说，看，在那边。那是梅利利亚。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
In the woods, there was this whole community of people. They'd organized themselves by country. There was a group from Mali and Gambia, Guinea, and one from his country, Cameroon. He slept with them that night.
在树林里，有一个完整的群体。他们按国家组织起来。有一群来自马里和冈比亚、几内亚的人，还有一群来自他的国家，喀麦隆。他那天晚上和他们睡在一起。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And that night, it really rained. And since I was new, I didn't have any place to sleep. And I didn't have any place to hide from all the water that was falling out of the sky.
那天晚上，真的下雨了。因为我是新人，我没有地方睡觉。我也没有地方躲避天上落下的雨水。
The next night, David and a small group he'd been traveling with went to check out the fences. But David said they didn't really know what they were doing. When they got there, they saw Moroccan border guards. David and the others figured, well, we'll just wait till they move. But hours went by. They waited until 2:00 AM, but always, there were guards.
第二天晚上，David和他一直在旅行的一小群人去检查了围栏。但David说他们并不真正知道自己在做什么。当他们到达那里时，他们看到了摩洛哥边境警卫。David和其他人想，好吧，我们就等他们离开。但几个小时过去了。他们一直等到凌晨2点，但总是有人守着。
The next time, he had better luck. One of the tricks the people in the forest told him was to go in large groups. If you've got the numbers, they can't catch all of you. So this time, David goes with a big group of 200 or 300 other people. It was early in the morning, 4:00 or 5:00 AM. They run toward the fences.
下一次，他运气好了一些。森林里的人告诉他的诀窍之一是组成大型团体。如果你人数够多，他们就抓不住所有人。所以这一次，David和一个200或300人的大团体一起行动。那是清晨，凌晨4点或5点。他们朝围栏跑去。
The first obstacle, before you can even get to the fences, is that trench. It's pretty deep, David says. He drops down into it OK, but getting out is hard. It's like six or seven feet straight up. He says everyone kind of helps each other. One person gets up, then pulls the next one up.
第一个障碍，在你甚至到达围栏之前，就是那条沟渠。它相当深，David说。他跳进去没事，但要爬出来很难。它有六七英尺直上直下。他说大家互相帮助。一个人上去，然后拉下一个人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I tried to get out of there, and there were Moroccan military people who were throwing stones. And there was a lot of noise. And people were moving around, and there was blood. And it was difficult to get out.
我试图从那里爬出来，有摩洛哥军人在扔石头。噪音很大。人们在四处走动，有血迹。爬出来很困难。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then I was climbing up the other side. And then I climbed up the first barrier. And I got to the second barrier, and then I said, OK, I finished that. I'm going to go to the third barrier.
然后我爬上了另一边。然后我爬过了第一道屏障。我到达了第二道屏障，然后我说，好吧，我完成了那个。我要去第三道屏障。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I don't know how to express it, but it was something strange. I was thinking, I'm going to do it. Then I thought, I can't do it. And then I was doing it, so I said, well, this is how it's done. I'm doing it. I'm doing it. But I don't know how to express it. That's the truth.
我不知道怎么表达，但这有些奇怪。我想着，我会做到的。然后我想，我做不到。然后我正在做，所以我说，好吧，就是这样。我在做。我在做。但我不知道怎么表达。这就是真相。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Did it feel like a crazy sport?
这感觉像是一项疯狂的运动吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Yeah, exactly. That's exactly what it is, the way you put it.
是的，正是如此。你说的就是它的感觉。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It was a weird sport.
这是一项奇怪的运动。
I usually think of a border wall or a fence as this thing that's supposed to stop someone. But as David was discovering, that's not how these things are actually designed. His opponents had a strategy too.
我通常认为边境墙或围栏是用来阻止某人的。但正如David所发现的，这些东西的设计目的并非如此。他的对手也有策略。
The Malilla border is an example of something called defense in depth. In the US, it's used around nuclear facilities. The idea is to have many layers. Each can be beat, but they slow you down enough so that, before you can get to the other side, the guards are there. In this case, to pick you up and send you back to start.
梅利利亚边境是被称为纵深防御的一个例子。在美国，它被用于核设施周围。其理念是拥有多层。每一层都可能被攻破，但它们会减慢你的速度，足以让警卫在到达另一侧之前赶到。在这种情况下，把你抓起来送回起点。
That's what happened to David that day. The guards got him before he could clear the final fence, and they sent him back to Morocco. He was frustrated, but also felt kind of good. He'd made it to the third fence on his first try.
这就是那天David发生的情况。警卫在他通过最后一道围栏前抓住了他，并将他送回了摩洛哥。他很沮丧，但也感觉不错。他第一次尝试就到了第三道围栏。
David returned to the camps in the forest, which he says is OK. But I think it's not what a lot of people would call OK. He had to dig around in trash cans for food. And sometimes after they'd gone to sleep, the Moroccan police would come and chase them out, destroy what they'd set up.
David回到了森林里的营地，他说这还行。但我认为这并不是许多人所说的还行。他必须在垃圾桶里翻找食物。有时在他们入睡后，摩洛哥警察会来把他们赶走，摧毁他们建立的营地。
When there was downtime, people would sometimes sit all facing the same direction and just kind of stare out at Malilla and talk about how to get past those damn fences. There were rules that have been passed down by people who'd gone before them with the goal of not making things harder for the next people trying to cross. One of the rules was no weapons-- another, no cutting the fence.
当有闲暇时，人们有时会坐在一起，面朝同一个方向，盯着梅利利亚，谈论如何越过那些该死的围栏。有些规则是由先他们而去的人传下来的，目的是不让下一个尝试越境的人处境更难。规则之一是没有武器——另一个，不切割围栏。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
We decided that it wasn't a good strategy because, at the end of the day, our goal was to be accepted by the Spaniards on the other side.
我们决定这不是一个好的策略，因为归根结底，我们的目标是被另一边的西班牙人接受。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So we didn't want to use knives, and we couldn't cut the fence.
所以我们不想用刀，也不能切割围栏。
They tried over and over, but it seemed impossible to beat the guards. They had cameras that could see at night and helicopters. David met people who'd been living in the forest for four or five years who still had never made it to Europe.
他们一次又一次地尝试，但似乎无法击败警卫。他们有能在夜间观察的摄像头和直升机。David遇到了已经在森林里生活了四五年的人，他们仍然从未进入过欧洲。
David checked out the fences around Ceuta, the other city, but again, no luck. He tried 20 times, 30 times. A year pased. At some point, it started to feel kind of crazy that this is what his life had become, trying to get over this barrier to this little piece of land.
David检查了休达（另一个城市）周围的围栏，但同样没有好运。他尝试了20次，30次。一年过去了。在某个时刻，这已成为他的生活，即试图翻越这道障碍进入那一小片土地，开始显得有些疯狂。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
There were times when it did appear absurd to me. Why am I doing this? What good is this? Especially when I experienced the failure, and I thought about just abandoning everything, and I would cry.
有几次它确实显得荒谬。我为什么要这么做？这有什么好处？特别是当我经历失败时，我想着放弃一切，我会哭泣。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But then you rest up two or three days. And once again, you think in an optimistic fashion. And I got my energy back.
但然后你休息两三天。再一次，你以乐观的态度去思考。我又恢复了能量。
I wondered what all this looked like from the other side of the fence, to live in one of these cities five or seven square miles in size with fences around it, where in some years, you get people rushing up every few weeks, this whole mass of people outside trying to get in. There's this one photo from the Spanish side of two people playing golf. They're standing on this lush green fairway, palm trees. One of them, a woman, is teeing off in a bright white golf outfit.
我想知道从围栏的另一边看这一切是什么样子，住在这些五到七平方英里、四周环绕着围栏的城市里，在某些年份，你会看到每隔几周就有人冲进来，外面有一大群人试图进入。西班牙一侧有一张两个人打高尔夫的照片。他们站在郁郁葱葱的绿色球道和棕榈树间。其中一个人，一名女性，穿着鲜艳的白色高尔夫球装正在开球。
And right behind them, there's the fence. And on top of the fence, about a dozen people straddling it. I couldn't find any surveys of how people in the towns felt about the fences. But one journalist who lives in Malilla told me that photo is kind of the way it is for a lot of people. They're used to it now.
而在他们身后，就是那道围栏。在围栏顶部，大约有十几个人骑在上面。我找不到任何关于镇上人们对这些围栏感觉的调查。但一位住在梅利利亚的记者告诉我，这张照片在很多方面就是人们的现状。他们现在习惯了。
When the fences started being built in the '90s, some people thought they were ugly or sad. But then the fences became something else. They became invisible.
当围栏在90年代开始修建时，有些人认为它们丑陋或悲伤。但后来围栏变成了别的东西。它们变得隐形了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's something more than a fence. I know it may seem silly, but--
这不仅仅是一道围栏。我知道这看起来可能很愚蠢，但是——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
There is something mystical in this fence. I've seen people who, when they get in front of the fence, they can't move.
这道围栏里有些神秘的东西。我见过人们在走到围栏前时，他们动弹不得。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I imagine that, if there are people from throughout the world who get together to make a fence, there must be a spirit inside the fence that tries to prevent things.
我想，如果世界上有来自各地的人聚在一起建一道围栏，围栏里一定有一种精神在试图阻止事情发生。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's really something very powerful. It's not just a fence.
这确实是非常强大的东西。它不仅仅是一道围栏。
Even a fence with a spirit in it is still a fence. And as with a lot of fences, if you follow them far enough, there is a place where they end. Malilla and Ceuta are not totally surrounded. They're on the coast. And where the fences hit the water, they stop. They go out a ways into the water, but then stop.
即使是一道有灵魂的围栏，它依然是一道围栏。正如许多围栏一样，如果你沿着它们走得足够远，总会有一个尽头。梅利利亚和休达并没有完全被包围。它们在海岸上。围栏碰到水的地方，它们就停下了。它们延伸进水里一点，然后就停了。
These places, of course, are very heavily guarded. And in the previous year, a bunch of people had died trying to cross this way. The Spanish police used tear gas and rubber bullets. At least 15 people drowned. And David can't swim.
这些地方当然守卫森严。在去年，一群人试图通过这种方式越境时死亡。西班牙警察使用了催泪瓦斯和橡胶子弹。至少15人溺水身亡。而David不会游泳。
But one day, in the forest around Ceuta, he runs into a group of people who want to try this place where the fence ends. By this time, he's been at it for a while. He knows the way. He helps lead them there.
但是有一天，在休达周围的森林里，他遇到了想尝试围栏尽头那块地方的一群人。到这个时候，他已经尝试了一段时间。他知道路。他帮忙带他们去那里。
There's no trench here and only a single fence. And so when it's dark out, David and a group sneak up to it through this wooded area. There are over a hundred of them, and they start running along the fence, trying to get to the beach and finally where it extends into the water.
这里没有沟渠，只有一道围栏。所以天黑后，David和一群人潜行通过这片树林。他们有超过一百人，开始沿着围栏奔跑，试图到达海滩，最终到达围栏延伸进水里的地方。
When they reach the beach, some people start trying to climb the fence. Guards are gathering, but David notices they aren't doing the thing that he's had problems with in the past. They aren't hitting people's fingers as they climb. So up he goes.
当他们到达海滩时，有些人开始尝试爬围栏。警卫正在集结，但David注意到他们没有做他过去遇到问题的行为。他们没有在人们攀爬时敲打他们的手指。所以他上去了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I put one finger on, and I put one hand on. Then I put one leg up. And I got up to the point where there were the knives.
我放了一根手指上去，又放了一只手上去。然后我抬起一条腿。我爬到了有刀片的地方。
He means the razor wire at the top.
他指的是顶部的刀片刺网。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And I tried to get higher up, but these knives we're grabbing at my clothes. And I had a backpack on, so I had to go down.
我试图再往上爬，但这些刀片抓住了我的衣服。我背着背包，所以我不得不下去。
But not all the way down. David and the others stay on the fence. They're just below the very top, maybe 18 feet off the ground. And they start clambering sideways, horizontally along the fence trying to get to the water.
但不是完全下去。David和其他人待在围栏上。他们在顶部下方，距离地面约18英尺。他们开始横向攀爬，沿着围栏水平移动，试图到达水边。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And there were two kids in front of us. One of them was really young. He was like 13 or 14.
我们前面有两个孩子。其中一个真的很年轻。他大约13或14岁。
They were moving very slowly.
他们移动得很慢。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And someone behind me said, hurry up, hurry up. And I said, look, the boys in front of us cannot go fast. We've got to go step by step.
我身后有人说，快点，快点。我说，看，我们前面的孩子快不起来。我们必须一步一步走。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
If we make it to the water, we'll be OK.
如果我们能到水边，我们就没问题了。
They get to the end of the fence. There are two people ahead of David. The first one jumps down.
他们到达了围栏尽头。David前面有两个人。第一个跳了下去。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And he fell into the water on the Moroccan side. And he was immediately picked up by the Moroccan soldiers. They picked him up and put him in a boat.
他掉进了摩洛哥一侧的水里。他立即被摩洛哥士兵抓住了。他们抓起他，把他放进了一艘船里。
Which seemed bad. A Moroccan guard would keep him in Morocco. The next guy is the kid in front of David. He jumps down onto the rocks at the base of the fence.
这看起来很糟糕。摩洛哥警卫会把他留在摩洛哥。下一个人是David前面的孩子。他跳到了围栏底部的岩石上。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And very quickly, hit the ground. And as soon as he hit the ground, the civil guard picked him up and put him aside.
很快就落地了。他一落地，国民警卫队就抓住了他，把他拉到一边。
David is next in line, the third to try.
David是队列中的下一个，第三个尝试的人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
At the moment that I saw the civil guard people moving two or three steps away, I went down immediately, just like the kid did. But as soon as I hit the ground--
当我看到国民警卫队的人移动了两三步远的那一刻，我和那个孩子一样立即下去了。但当我一落地——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I went right into the water.
我直接跳进了水里。
Then others make it into the water. They sit on this big rock.
然后其他人也跳进了水里。他们坐在那块大石头上。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The little kid, who the police, the civil guard, had picked up and already had his hands tied behind his back, tried to escape and make it into the water.
那个小孩子，警察（国民警卫队）已经抓住并把他的手绑在身后，试图逃脱并跳进水里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And just to show, one of us was brave enough to go into the water, and he saved him and brought him over to the stone.
为了展示，我们中有一个人足够勇敢地进入水中，他救了他并把他带到了石头上。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So then we were singing and shouting.
所以那时我们都在唱歌和呐喊。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The civil guard was saying--
国民警卫队一直在说——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Get out of the water. Come out of the water, and nothing's going to happen to you.
从水里出来。从水里出来，什么都不会发生在你身上。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And there were many negotiations to get us out of the water.
我们进行了很多谈判才从水里出来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And we didn't want to get out.
我们不想出来。
This goes on for hours. They're cold, but singing and shouting, waiting for the city to wake up, hoping someone will come and help them-- the Red Cross, journalists. Eventually, they do get out of the water. They're taken to a police station and fingerprinted. David figured he'd be sent back to Morocco like all the other times.
这种情况持续了几个小时。他们很冷，但在唱歌呐喊，等待城市醒来，希望有人会来帮助他们——红十字会、记者。最终，他们确实从水里出来了。他们被带到警察局并录入指纹。David以为他会像往常一样被送回摩洛哥。
The police station was right there on the border. But it didn't happen. Instead, someone got him some food and a place to sleep. After almost two years of attempts, he'd made it. He felt joy, like, is this really happening? For a couple of days-- and then he felt something else.
警察局就在边境。但并没有发生。相反，有人给了他食物和一个睡觉的地方。在近两年的尝试后，他成功了。他感到喜悦，就像，这真的发生了吗？过了几天——然后他感到了另一种东西。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
When I realized that I had made it, it was like a vacuum.
当我意识到我成功了，那就像一个真空。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
That's the truth.
这就是真相。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
When we are in Morocco, we think that whenever I manage to get there, I'm going to be very happy.
当我们在摩洛哥时，我们认为只要我设法到了那里，我会非常快乐。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But once you make it--
但一旦你成功了——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
--you don't feel anything.
——你什么感觉都没有。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The feeling ends.
那种感觉结束了。
David is in Madrid now. In a little bit, he'll be able to apply for residency so he can work. After almost two years thinking about the fence, he doesn't anymore. It was just a barrier, one among many.
David现在在马德里。很快，他就能申请居住权以便工作。在思考围栏近两年后，他不再想了。它只是一道障碍，众多障碍中的一个。
David Kestenbaum is one of the producers of our program.
David Kestenbaum是我们节目的制作人之一。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
David from that story is trying to make it as a musician. He wrote this song about the border fence.
故事中的David正试图成为一名音乐家。他写了这首关于边境围栏的歌。
[MUSIC - "BARRIER DE POLICE" BY DAVID]
[音乐 - David演唱的“BARRIER DE POLICE”]
(NON-ENGLISH SINGING)
（非英语演唱）
Coming up, the wall that is 150 miles long and completely invisible from one of its sides. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，那是150英里长、从一侧看完全隐形的墙。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Walls." We have stories from around the globe looking at the way that life morphs and adapts around any wall that gets built anywhere. A version of today's program was first broadcast last year, but we thought we would update and bring it back with our government shut down over a wall.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“墙”。我们有来自全球各地的故事，探讨了生活如何围绕着任何建造的墙进行变形和适应。今天节目的一版去年首次播出，但我们认为随着政府因墙而关闭，我们应该更新并重播它。
And one thing that I've found myself thinking about a lot these last few weeks has been the president's promise to have Mexico pay for the wall. And I think a lot of people don't remember that that just wasn't a thing that was said in rallies. There was an actual step by step plan on how to do it. And I've wondered, whatever happened to that?
过去几周我一直在思考的一件事是总统承诺让墨西哥为墙买单。我想很多人不记得这不仅仅是集会上说的一句话。有一个实际的一步步计划来执行它。我一直想知道，那个计划怎么了？
It's the long forgotten plan from the Trump campaign. We talk now like this plan never even existed.
这是特朗普竞选活动中被遗忘已久的计划。我们现在说得好像这个计划从未存在过一样。
This is Robert Costa, national political reporter for the Washington Post. He says that when he and Bob Woodward asked then-candidate Trump in 2016 for details about exactly how he would pay for his wall, to their surprise, two days later, they got this step by step memo outlining how it would happen, written, he says, by Stephen Miller, now one of the president's top aides.
这位是《华盛顿邮报》的全国政治记者Robert Costa。他说，当他和Bob Woodward在2016年要求当时的候选人特朗普提供关于他究竟如何让墨西哥为墙买单的细节时，令他们惊讶的是，两天后，他们收到了这份概述该计划如何实现的逐项备忘录，他说，这是由现在的总统高级助手之一Stephen Miller撰写的。
This is something that the Trump campaign was under intense pressure during the primary season to prove that, in some way, it had a serious proposal for getting Mexico to pay for the wall. And this is what they came up with.
在初选期间，特朗普竞选团队面临巨大压力，要证明它在某种程度上有一个严肃的提案来让墨西哥为墙买单。这就是他们提出的方案。
Here's the plan. They say that under the Patriot Act, the president has powers to do all kinds of things, including, if he wants to, he can make it impossible for undocumented Mexicans living here to wire money home to Mexico. And it's a lot of money, the memo says, $24 billion a year. The actual number is probably much smaller than that, but still in the billions, significant to the Mexican economy.
这是计划。他们说，根据《爱国者法案》，总统拥有做各种事情的权力，包括如果他愿意，他可以使在此居住的无证墨西哥人无法将钱汇回墨西哥。备忘录称，这可是一大笔钱，每年240亿美元。实际数字可能要小得多，但仍有数十亿之巨，这对墨西哥经济意义重大。
Mexico, as the memo notes, would not like this. And so the memo says we would tell the Mexican government that it could avoid all this unpleasantness if it would just send us $5 to $10 billion for the wall. And then we won't make the change to our regulations. We will let people wire money home to Mexico.
正如备忘录指出的，墨西哥不会喜欢这样。所以备忘录说，我们会告诉墨西哥政府，如果它能向我们支付50亿到100亿美元建墙，它就可以避免这一切不快。然后我们就不会改变我们的法规。我们将允许人们汇款回墨西哥。
It said in typical language by President Trump, it's, quote, "an easy decision for Mexico to make," and that all they need to do is make a, quote, "one-time payment of $5 to 10 billion for the wall," and then they could walk away.
它用特朗普总统典型的语言写道，这引用，是“墨西哥的一个容易做出的决定”，他们所需要做的只是引用，“一次性支付50到100亿美元建墙”，然后他们就可以走人了。
If that didn't work, the memo lists other threats that we could make. Trade tariffs-- we could cancel work and tourist visas. We could charge higher visa fees, all with the idea that this would force Mexico to cough up billions for the wall.
如果这不起作用，备忘录列出了我们可以采取的其他威胁。贸易关税——我们可以取消工作和旅游签证。我们可以收取更高的签证费，所有这些都是为了迫使墨西哥为墙掏出数十亿美元。
Do we know if they tried to do any of this once they got into office?
我们知道他们上任后是否尝试过这些做法中的任何一个吗？
We're actually poking around about that at the Washington Post. It seems like John Kelly, when he was head of DHS, and Kirstjen Nielsen, now head of DHS, they have not pursued this kind of policy to an extent. But the idea that it's floating around in Trump circles remains. Bannon always would hover it out there in 2017 when he was in the White House as something that would maybe be brought up. And it could still be brought up. He believes he has sweeping executive authority to do this sort of thing.
我们实际上正在《华盛顿邮报》对此进行调查。看起来当John Kelly担任国土安全部长和Kirstjen Nielsen现在担任国土安全部长时，他们并没有在很大程度上推行这种政策。但它在特朗普圈子中流传的想法仍然存在。Bannon在2017年还在白宫时，总是会把它挂在嘴边，作为也许会被提出来的事情。而且它仍然可能被提出来。他相信自己拥有广泛的行政权力来做这类事情。
There have been bills in Congress to do a more straightforward version of this by just taxing the money that gets wired to Mexico and do some of the other things that the memo suggests. There was a bill in 2017, another in 2018. Neither picked up many co-sponsors or ever got to a vote.
国会曾有法案通过对汇往墨西哥的钱征税并采取备忘录建议的其他一些做法来执行该计划的更直接版本。2017年有一个法案，2018年又有另一个。两者都没有获得多少共同提案人，也从未进行投票。
On Friday, the president said that he might declare a state of emergency to pay for his border wall, which would give him a bunch of options, a bunch of powers, none of them apparently related to this memo or Mexico paying for the wall. Presumably, the memo still sits there somewhere in the White House, untouched, ready for action, Plan A.
周五，总统表示他可能会宣布国家紧急状态来支付他的边境墙，这将给他一系列选择，一系列权力，显然都与这份备忘录或墨西哥为墙买单无关。大概这份备忘录仍然存放在白宫的某个地方，无人触碰，等待行动，A计划。
Act Two, "No One Has Seen Them Made or Heard Them Made."
第二幕，“没有人见过或听说过它们的制造”。
Of all the walls all over the world that we learned about for today's program, this next one is the most mysterious-- a wall that may or may not even exist. Brian Reed looked into it.
在我们今天节目中了解到的世界各地所有的墙中，接下来这一个是最神秘的——一堵可能存在也可能不存在的墙。Brian Reed对此进行了调查。
I read about this possible wall in a blog post. It's a travel blog by an Australian guy, and he tells the story of a bizarre tour he took in North Korea. The post is titled, "North Korea's Loch Ness Monster, The Concrete Wall."
我在一篇博客文章中读到了这个可能的墙。那是一个澳大利亚人的旅游博客，他讲述了他在朝鲜参加的一次离奇旅行。文章的标题是，“朝鲜的尼斯湖水怪，混凝土墙”。
For decades, the North Korean government has complained about the huge Concrete Wall that divides North and South Korea, a wall, it claims, that South Korea put up at the urging of the United States as a permanent barrier to reunification, a wall that's been a source of anger for the North Koreans for years. For them, it's a symbol of the duplicity and bad will of South Korea.
几十年来，朝鲜政府一直抱怨分裂南北韩的那堵巨大的“混凝土墙”，它声称这是韩国在美国的怂恿下建立的，作为统一的永久障碍，这堵墙多年来一直是朝鲜愤怒的根源。对他们来说，这是韩国虚伪和恶意的象征。
One peculiar thing about this wall, though, North Korea says it can only be seen from the northern side, that you can't see it from the south. It also doesn't show up on Google Earth or satellite images. But in North Korea, there's a place where tourists can go see it. That's where the blogger went.
然而，这堵墙的一个独特之处在于，朝鲜说它只能从北侧看到，你无法从南侧看到它。它也不会出现在谷歌地球或卫星图像上。但在朝鲜，有一个游客可以去观看它的地方。这就是那个博主去的地方。
According to the post, he arrived at a small bunker where a North Korean colonel delivers a whole lecture about the Concrete Wall. He stands there in uniform with a pointer stick-- there's a photo of this on the blog-- with a big mural behind him of the wall snaking along the border. Though, curiously, it's not a photograph of the wall. It's a painting.
根据文章，他到达了一个小地堡，那里的一名朝鲜上校发表了关于混凝土墙的演讲。他身着制服，拿着一根指示棒——博客上有一张照片——身后是一幅巨大的墙壁沿边境蜿蜒的壁画。虽然奇怪的是，那不是墙的照片。那是一幅画。
The colonel runs through the wall's dimensions, which are listed on the mural, as well as geometric diagrams demonstrating the ingenious engineering that makes it only visible from the North. It's built into a hill, so from the South it just looks like green land. It's invisible. Which, the colonel explains, allows South Korea and the United States to claim that there isn't a wall between North and South Korea, which is exactly what those countries say.
上校讲述了壁画上列出的墙的尺寸，以及演示其巧妙工程的几何图表，这使得它只能从北方看到。它是建在山里的，所以从南方看它看起来就像绿地。它是隐形的。正如上校解释的那样，这使得韩国和美国可以声称南北韩之间没有墙，而这正是这些国家所说的。
And then, the colonel invites the tour group outside to see for themselves. The blogger is handed a pair of binoculars. The blogger writes that he half expects there to be a stencil of a wall taped on the lenses when he looked through. There isn't. But as he stares out from the observation deck into the DMZ, or Demilitarized Zone, the four kilometer-wide stretch of land that buffers North Korea from South, he does see something.
然后，上校邀请旅游团到外面亲自去看。博主被递给了一副双筒望远镜。博主写道，他在看的时候半期待镜头上会贴着墙的模板。并没有。但当他从观察台凝视非军事区（DMZ）时——那条缓冲南北韩的四公里宽的土地——他确实看到了一些东西。
He includes a photo he took of it. Could this be what the North Koreans were talking about, he writes? Lean in and see what you make of it.
他附上了他拍的一张照片。这可能是朝鲜人所说的那堵墙吗？他写道。凑近看看你觉得它是什麽。
I did lean in. And honestly, I could not tell what the hell was going on in this photo. It's super blurry, taken from kilometers away on a hazy-looking day. There are shrubs and hills in the DMZ, and then, yeah, some type of brownish structure on top of the hills. But it's really hard to make out. It is like one of those Loch Ness photos.
我确实凑近了。老实说，我看不出这张照片里到底发生了什么。它非常模糊，是在几公里外一个朦胧的日子里拍的。非军事区里有灌木和山丘，然后，是的，山丘顶上确实有一些棕色的结构。但这真的很难辨认。就像尼斯湖水怪的照片之一。
This blog post confused me. Was there a wall between North and South Korea, or not? The news media seemed unequivocal on this question. The reports I read said the wall's not real. One headline from Reuters-- "North Korea asks South to tear down imaginary wall."
这篇博客文章让我困惑。南北韩之间到底有没有墙？新闻媒体在这个问题上似乎很明确。我读到的报道说那堵墙不是真的。路透社的一条标题——“朝鲜要求韩国拆除虚构的墙”。
The blogger didn't want to be interviewed. So I ended up on the phone instead with a tour guide, named Simon Cockerell, who runs one of the most popular tour companies that takes people into North Korea. Simon says he's been in North Korea more than 160 times.
博主不想接受采访。所以我最终和一位名叫Simon Cockerell的导游通了电话，他经营着带人进入朝鲜的最受欢迎的旅游公司之一。Simon说他已经去过朝鲜160多次了。
So I've been even nearly to the Concrete Wall itself.
所以我甚至差点就到了混凝土墙本身。
You've been nearly to the Concrete Wall itself?
你差点就到了混凝土墙本身？
Yes, that's right.
是的，没错。
So it is a wall. It is a thing. It exists. You're talking about it as if it exists.
所以它是一堵墙。它是一个东西。它存在。你说得好像它存在一样。
It, in some way, entirely does exist.
它在某种程度上完全存在。
Simon says he's done that whole tour the Australian blogger did.
Simon说他完成了那个澳大利亚博主做的整个旅行。
How many times have you seen this wall?
你见过这堵墙多少次？
I would have to guess, maybe 40 or 50 times.
我得猜猜，也许40或50次。
Did you ever, in any of those viewings, question whether what you were looking at was a wall?
你在任何一次观察中质疑过你看到的是否是一堵墙吗？
I honestly don't think I did. I mean, it's not a hologram. I mean, there's probably a semantic case to be made that it's not a wall because, on the southern side of it, it's a hill. And on the northern side of it, it's a wall. So it has the characteristics of a wall, if you're looking at it from the North, which after all is the only side from which you can see it.
老实说，我想我没有。我的意思是，它不是全息图。我的意思是，可能有一个语义上的理由可以说它不是一堵墙，因为在它的南侧，它是一座山。而在它的北侧，它是一堵墙。所以它具备墙的特征，如果你是从北方看它，毕竟这是你唯一能看到它的那一侧。
What are the characteristics of a wall, as you see them?
在你看来，墙的特征是什么？
It rises at a 90 degree angle from the ground, and it creates a barrier between where you are and the place on the other side of the wall.
它从地面以90度角升起，并创造了一个障碍，将你所在的地方与墙另一边的地方隔开。
That's what exists in the DMZ.
这就是在非军事区存在的东西。
It's, at the very least, a wall-like object.
它至少是一个类似墙的物体。
There's a headline I want to read you from a journalist, Jon Herskovitz, who was based in Seoul for years and followed North Korea.
有一条标题我想读给你听，来自一名叫Jon Herskovitz的记者，他在首尔待了多年，关注朝鲜。
I know Jon Herskovitz.
我认识Jon Herskovitz。
Oh, you know Jon? OK, he wrote this article. I believe this was back in 2007, in Reuters. The headline is, "One of the greatest hindrances to tearing down the wall is that it doesn't exist."
哦，你认识Jon？好的，他写了这篇文章。我相信那是2007年，在路透社。标题是，“拆除那堵墙的最大障碍之一是它根本不存在”。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
What do you make of that headline?
你觉得那个标题怎么样？
It's poetic. It sounds good. It's just not true.
很有诗意。听起来不错。只是不是真的。
Really? So it's just straight up not true in your eyes.
真的？所以这在你看法里完全不是真的。
It's not really "in my eyes." It's sort of manifestly untrue. Yeah, Jon is 100% wrong about that.
这不完全是“在我的眼中”。这简直是明显不真实。是的，Jon对此百分之百错了。
He said something to the effect of "Jon is 100% wrong."
他说的话大意是“Jon百分之百错了”。
Ugh.
啊。
That "ugh" is Reuters journalist, reporter in Korea for five years, and author of the article with that headline, Jon Herskovitz. And he sticks to his guns-- no wall.
那个“啊”是路透社记者、在韩国报道了五年的记者，以及那篇标题文章的作者Jon Herskovitz。他坚持自己的立场——没有墙。
How do you know there's no wall?
你怎么知道没有墙？
I've been to the border numerous times and also have crossed through the DMZ four times.
我多次去过边境，也四次穿越了非军事区。
And did you have to traverse a wall at any point?
你在任何时候不得不穿越一堵墙吗？
No. I had to go through some razor wire and boom gates, but there was no wall to traverse.
没有。我不得不通过一些铁丝网和栅栏门，但没有墙需要穿越。
And when you looked left and right as you were crossing, did you see a wall anywhere?
当你穿越时向左和向右看，你看到哪里有墙吗？
I didn't see a wall. There is no wall.
我没看到墙。根本没有墙。
All that said, Jon may have been to the border a bunch of times, but he has not been to the observation point in the North that the blogger and Simon went to. He hasn't tried to view the wall from North Korea, which is convenient.
话虽如此，Jon可能去过边境很多次，但他没去过博主和Simon去的北方观察点。他没尝试过从朝鲜观看这堵墙，这很方便。
So the fact that North Korea says you can't see the wall from the South, which is where you were looking for the wall--
所以朝鲜说你无法从南方看到墙，而你是在那里寻找墙——这一事实——
Yes.
是的。
That doesn't make you wonder if maybe there's a wall?
这没让你怀疑是否可能有一堵墙吗？
No, it doesn't, because they are very specific about what they have described. They describe it very distinctly as five to eight meters tall, 19 meters thick, and stretches from one end of the peninsula to the other.
没有，这没让我怀疑，因为他们对所描述的东西非常具体。他们非常清楚地将其描述为五到八米高，19米厚，从半岛的一端延伸到另一端。
Jon says it'd be hard to miss a giant concrete barrier that's 62 feet thick, several stories high, running for more than 150 miles across the Korean peninsula. In the decades this wall's supposedly been around, someone would have bumped into it or glimpsed it on satellite. I told Jon I'd actually just talked to someone who says they've glimpsed it with their own eyes 40 or more times, the tour guide, Simon.
Jon说很难错过一个62英尺厚、几层楼高、在朝鲜半岛横跨超过150英里的巨大混凝土屏障。在据说这堵墙存在的几十年里，有人会碰到它或在卫星上瞥见它。我告诉Jon我刚刚和一个人谈过，他说他亲眼瞥见它40次或更多次了，那个导游，Simon。
I'm guessing that he probably saw one of these tank barriers.
我猜他可能看到的是这些坦克障碍物之一。
Tank barriers, or anti-tank barriers-- Jon admits that these do exist in the DMZ between North and South Korea. South Korea's also copped to this. They're tall. They're big. You can't walk through them. They may even be made of concrete. But they do not come close to spanning the entire length of the peninsula, like North Korea claims.
坦克障碍物，或反坦克障碍物——Jon承认这些确实存在于南北韩之间的非军事区。韩国也承认了这一点。它们很高。它们很大。你无法走过去。它们甚至可能是由混凝土制成的。但它们远没有跨越半岛的全长，不像朝鲜声称的那样。
Simon, the tour guide, admits he's only ever seen the wall from one spot. He doesn't know if it stretches the entire peninsula. He only knows what he knows, which is that claiming there's no wall, to him, is absurd.
导游Simon承认他只在一个地方见过这堵墙。他不知道它是否延伸整个半岛。他只知道他知道的，即声称没有墙对他来说是荒谬的。
It's probably a tank barrier, as well. I mean, what's the purpose of a wall? Keep something out, or keep something in. And yeah, tanks are a thing. I think an anti-tank barrier can also be described as being a wall.
这也可能是一个坦克障碍物。我的意思是，墙的目的是什么？把东西挡在外面，或者把东西关在里面。是的，坦克是现实。我认为反坦克障碍也可以被描述为墙。
It's like going to the Great Wall of China, an anti-invading forces barrier. Hadrian's Wall is a wall, not just an anti-Scots barrier. I mean, what's the difference?
就像去中国的长城，一个反入侵力量的障碍。哈德良长城是一堵墙，不仅仅是一个反苏格兰人的障碍。我的意思是，有什么区别？
It might seem silly to get into a semantic debate over the meaning of the word "wall," but that's where we are. When it comes to walls, apparently semantics matter. Jon pointed out to me that the Demilitarized Zone between North and South Korea is probably the most fortified border in the world.
陷入关于“墙”一词含义的语义争论可能看起来很愚蠢，但这正是我们的处境。当谈到墙时，显然语义很重要。Jon向我指出，南北韩之间的非军事区可能是世界上防卫最严密的边境。
There's razor wire fence on either side of it that does stretch across the entire peninsula. There are landmines everywhere inside. North and South Korea have about 2 million troops on either edge, with artillery and missiles and air forces at the ready.
在它两侧有延伸整个半岛的铁丝网围栏。内部到处都是地雷。南北韩在每一侧都有约200万军队，配备火炮、导弹和空军。
This border does not need a concrete wall to stop people from crossing it or attacking, and yet the North Koreans felt the need to invent one anyway. It needed to be a wall. Even if it doesn't do much to actually stop people, even if it's imaginary, calling it a wall makes a difference.
这个边境不需要混凝土墙来阻止人们穿越或攻击，但朝鲜无论如何都觉得有必要发明一个。它必须是一堵墙。即使它对真正阻止人们起不了多大作用，即使它是虚构的，称之为墙也会带来不同。
Brian Reed is the senior producer of our program and the host of the podcast S-Town.
Brian Reed是我们节目的高级制作人，也是播客《S-Town》的主持人。
Act Three, "He Is All Pine, and I Am Apple Orchard."
第三幕，“他是松树，我是苹果园”。
Our next story takes place at the border between Pakistan and India. Nearly 2,000 miles, the border is heavily patrolled, lit at night, fenced in parts, a border between two countries that have gone to war four times-- 1947, 1965, 1971, and 1999.
我们的下一个故事发生在巴基斯坦和印度之间的边境。近2000英里的边境受到严密巡逻，夜间照明，部分设有围栏，这是两个已经发生过四次战争的国家——1947年、1965年、1971年和1999年的边境。
It is still tense between India and Pakistan. Each has nuclear weapons. And there's only one road on that long, long border where you can cross from one country into the other, and that's in a town called Wagah, at a place they call the Berlin Wall of Asia.
印巴之间仍然紧张。双方都拥有核武器。在那条漫长的边境线上，只有一条路可以从一个国家越过到另一个国家，那就是在一个叫瓦格赫的城镇，在他们所说的亚洲柏林墙的地方。
Mariya Karimjee grew up in Pakistan. And the thing that she knew about Wagah was that they do this flag lowering ceremony there. It happens every day at sundown. Soldiers from both sides of the border do this elaborate, stylized, choreographed performance. Here's Mariya.
Mariya Karimjee在巴基斯坦长大。她关于瓦格赫所知道的事情是，他们在那里举行降旗仪式。它每天在日落时分举行。边境两侧的士兵进行这种精心制作的、风格化的、编排好的表演。这是Mariya。
As a kid, I only knew the bare bones of what happened at Wagah. I knew there was some kind of marching, flags being lowered, a handshake. It's the handshake, the idea of the handshake, that got me.
小时候，我只知道瓦格赫发生的事情的基本梗概。我知道有一些行军，旗帜降下，握手。是握手，那个握手的想法吸引了我。
An Indian soldier walks right up to the border and shakes a Pakistani soldier's hand. I loved it. It seemed so sweet. I'd always liked it whenever there was anything on TV showing our two countries getting along.
一名印度士兵走到边境直接和一名巴基斯坦士兵握手。我爱死它了。它看起来太甜了。每当电视上出现我们两个国家和睦相处的画面时，我总会喜欢。
There'd be news reports of soldiers exchanging treats during religious holidays, standing across from one another with their comical wax mustaches raised in a smile. I saw a commercial in which border security officers stationed at Wagah shared a soda across the border. I liked the idea of these soldiers as friends, a border where everyone was chummy and spent a lot of time together.
会有士兵在宗教节日期间交换零食的新闻报道，他们站在彼此对面，脸上带着滑稽的蜡质胡须和微笑。我看到一个广告，瓦格赫的边境安全官员在边境分享一瓶苏打水。我喜欢这些士兵作为朋友的想法，一个每个人都很亲密且花很多时间在一起的边境。
I never actually went there as a kid. My family and I moved to Texas when I was 11, and I lived in the US on and off since then. Last year, my mother and I went to Wagah for the first time. It was not what I expected.
我小时候从未真正去过那里。我和家人在我11岁时搬到了德克萨斯，从那以后我断断续续地住在美国。去年，我和我母亲第一次去了瓦格赫。那不是我预期的样子。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I knew there'd be goosestepping. But if you've never seen a goosestep, nothing can really prepare you for a formation of tall Pakistani men, a dozen of them, in black military uniforms, handlebar mustaches, and turbans topped with large pleated bands swinging their legs up in unison without bending at the knee, and without missing a beat, quickly doing it again on the other foot. And again, it's a march. It's impressive.
我知道会有鹅步。但如果你从未见过鹅步，没有什么能真正让你为一个由高大的巴基斯坦男子组成的方阵做好准备，他们中有一打，穿着黑色军装，八字胡，戴着上面有褶皱带的缠头巾，在不弯曲膝盖的情况下一致地摆动双腿，并且不错过任何节拍，快速地又换另一只脚。再说一次，这是一种行军。令人印象深刻。
[BOOTS CLICKING]
[靴子敲击声]
That's the crack of soldier's heels as they strike the ground. Then they switch to sky high kicks, their arms aggressively swinging to this exaggerated marching, looking a little like willful, frustrated toddlers. Someone on a PA leads the group in a series of chants.
那是士兵脚后跟撞击地面时的响声。然后他们切换到向天空猛踢，手臂随着夸张的行军剧烈摆动，看起来有点像任性、沮丧的幼儿。扩音器里的某个人带领大家进行一系列口号呼喊。
[SHOUTING] Pakistan, Pakistan. Pakistan is our home. Pakistan is our home.
[喊叫声] 巴基斯坦，巴基斯坦。巴基斯坦是我们的家。巴基斯坦是我们的家。
The gates to the Indian side were closed. But over there, I know the Indian soldiers were doing the same choreography, same goosesteps, same high kicks. They also look nearly identical to Pakistan's soldiers-- military uniforms and shiny black boots with turban hats.
通往印度一侧的大门关闭了。但在那边，我知道印度士兵也在做同样的动作，同样的鹅步，同样的高踢。他们看起来也几乎和巴基斯坦士兵一样——军装和闪亮的黑靴子，戴着缠头巾帽子。
The two sides rehearse together. I like to picture that, them learning the steps, one Indian soldier asking a Pakistani soldier to go over the ending one more time, another showing off a new stretch he learned to loosen up his glutes, a frustrated stage manager counting angrily, "5, 6, 7, 8, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]."
双方一起排练。我喜欢想象那个画面，他们学习步伐，一名印度士兵要求一名巴基斯坦士兵再过一遍结尾，另一名展示了他学到的新伸展动作来放松臀部，一个沮丧的舞台经理愤怒地数着，“5, 6, 7, 8, [非英语讲话]”。
The ceremony started in 1959 as an act of brotherhood and friendship between the two countries. And before visiting, I assumed that people came here to celebrate that. But in reality, the petty rivalries between the countries play out right in front of you.
仪式始于1959年，作为两国之间兄弟情谊和友谊的行为。而在访问之前，我以为人们来到这里是为了庆祝这一点。但实际上，两国之间琐碎的对抗就在你面前上演。
Pakistan recruits their tallest, brawniest men, soldiers that are 6 feet or taller in a country where the average height for men is 5' 5". Pakistan pays their soldiers extra for staying in shape. India just doesn't seem to care that much. Their soldiers look scrawny by comparison.
巴基斯坦招募了他们最高大、最强壮的男人，身高6英尺或以上的士兵，而在一个男性平均身高只有5英尺5英寸的国家。巴基斯坦为保持体形的士兵支付额外费用。印度似乎并不太在意。相比之下，他们的士兵看起来瘦骨嶙峋。
At the same time, India seems like it can't resist showing off that it's the wealthier country. They built a majestic stadium that seats 15,000. It towers over everything, the whole ceremony, no matter which side you are sitting on. The Pakistan side, it's way smaller, rows of little plastic seats surrounded by concrete steps.
同时，印度似乎无法抵挡展示自己是更富裕国家的需求。他们建造了一个雄伟的体育场，可容纳15000人。它高耸于一切之上，整个仪式，无论你坐在哪一侧。巴基斯坦一侧，它要小得多，一排排小塑料座椅，周围是混凝土台阶。
But what surprised me most at Wagah? There was an aggression I hadn't expected. It seemed like everyone was there to hate on India. The energy was frantic and hostile. People shook their fists at the Indians across from them.
但最让我感到惊讶的是什么？瓦格赫有一种我没预料到的侵略性。似乎每个人都在那里憎恨印度。那种能量是疯狂且敌对的。人们向他们对面的印度人挥舞拳头。
[CHANTING] Allah! Allah! Allah! Allah!
[口号声] 真主！真主！真主！真主！
The crowd was intense, shouting things like, "Allah is great," and "long live Pakistan."
人群很热烈，高呼着诸如“真主至大”和“巴基斯坦万岁”之类的口号。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Pakistan! [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Pakistan!
[非英语讲话] 巴基斯坦！[非英语讲话] 巴基斯坦！
A few weeks ago, I returned to Wagah, and everyone I spoke to seemed to really, really hate India. The mom whose kids wanted ice cream, the teenager dressed in pink, the ex-military man and his wife, they told me they'd come out to show their national pride and to teach their kids about history. But they also went on in great detail with these crackpot conspiracy theories, like the Taliban are actually Indians, or that India continues to attack Pakistan across the Kashmir border, unprovoked, or that India was working stealthily to destabilize the government from the inside.
几周前，我回到了瓦格赫，我交谈过的每一个人似乎都真的、真的很讨厌印度。那个想要冰淇淋的孩子们的妈妈，那个穿着粉色的青少年，那个前军人及其妻子，他们告诉我他们出来是为了展示民族自豪感并教他们的孩子历史。但他们也详细说了这些古怪的阴谋论，比如塔利班实际上是印度人，或者印度继续在克什米尔边境无端攻击巴基斯坦，或者印度正在暗中从内部破坏政府的稳定。
I felt dumb. I hadn't realized the extent of the hate and hostility that people still feel towards India. I told people, personally, I don't feel deeply about India. And I definitely don't think of India as an enemy. Almost everyone said that's because I'm too Western, and I didn't really know how it was in Pakistan. I couldn't possibly understand. Here at the border, it felt like my country, Pakistan, the underdog, was giving the middle finger to our neighboring country.
我感到很傻。我没意识到人们对印度仍然感受到的仇恨和敌意的程度。我告诉人们，个人而言，我对印度没有深切的感受。我也绝对不认为印度是敌人。几乎所有人都说那是因为我太西化了，而且我不真正了解巴基斯坦的情况。我不可能理解。在这里，在边境，感觉就像我的国家——巴基斯坦——作为弱者，正在向我们的邻国竖起中指。
And maybe India was no better. A Pakistani friend who visited the India side of the ceremony said he cried when he realized just how much the Indians hated the Pakistanis. "Let's rape their sisters," he overheard an Indian spectator yelling. It's like if people from all over the United States and Mexico, full of anger, were to travel to the border between El Paso and Juarez to sit in some bleachers and face off, both shouting insults and screaming, "I'm better than you."
也许印度也没好到哪里去。一位访问过印度仪式一侧的巴基斯坦朋友说，当他意识到印度人有多么讨厌巴基斯坦人时，他哭了。“让我们强奸她们的姐妹，”他听到一名印度观众大喊。这就像如果来自美国和墨西哥各地、充满愤怒的人们，要去埃尔帕索和华雷斯之间的边境坐在看台上对峙，双方都大声辱骂并尖叫着，“我比你强。”
At the stadium, the moment comes when the gates open between the two sides, and we can finally see the Indian soldiers. The Pakistani and Indian troops stare each other down, pause, then high kick their legs up into the air, like a competition between manly Rockettes. The crowd howls.
在体育场，大门在双方之间打开的时刻到来了，我们终于可以看到印度士兵了。巴基斯坦和印度军队相互对视，暂停，然后将双腿踢向空中，就像男性火箭女郎之间的竞争一样。人群嚎叫起来。
In 2006, before some peace talks, India slightly lowered the height of their kicks. It was a gesture of goodwill, meant to show how sincere India was about improving relations between the two nuclear armed countries. They thought Pakistan would reciprocate. We did not.
2006年，在一些和平谈判之前，印度略微降低了踢腿的高度。这是一个善意的姿态，意在展示印度对改善这两个拥核国家之间关系的诚意。他们认为巴基斯坦会投桃报李。我们没有。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Finally, Pakistan and India lower their respective flags for the night. Bugles play.
最后，巴基斯坦和印度为夜晚降下了各自的旗帜。号角声响起。
[BUGLES PLAYING]
[号角声响起]
All the soldiers fall back, except for one Pakistani and one Indian. Face to face, feet apart, they each do a single, beautifully executed high kick in the other's face. And then, as promised, they shake hands, woodenly, before marching back to their troops. The ceremony is done.
所有的士兵退后，除了一个巴基斯坦人和一个印度人。面对面，双脚分开，他们每个人都对着对方的脸做了一个单次、执行得非常优美的踢腿。然后，如承诺的那样，他们在行军回到各自部队之前，木然地握了握手。仪式结束了。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I will say, the handshake, I was glad to see it. I found it surprisingly moving in spite of my surroundings. I wondered if I was the only one who felt that way.
我会说，握手时，我很高兴看到它。尽管周围环境如此，我发现它意外地感人。我不知道是否只有我有这种感觉。
In the weeks since I went, I've thought a lot about how much emotion I saw pour out of people at Wagah. There's lots to be frustrated about in Pakistan. There's sectarian violence almost every single day. Politicians are nicknamed for how corrupt they are. Water is increasingly scarce. Police often don't follow up on crimes. The rich avoid paying taxes. You can't fight injustice through the legal system.
在我去过之后的几周里，我思考了很多关于我在瓦格赫看到人们流露出的情感。在巴基斯坦有很多让人沮丧的事情。几乎每天都有教派暴力。政治家们因贪腐而获得绰号。水资源日益稀缺。警察通常不对罪行进行跟进。富人避免纳税。你无法通过法律制度来对抗不公正。
At Wagah, the single spot on the giant line that made Pakistan exist as a country, you can at least yell with some ferocity. Maybe it is a way to show your love for Pakistan. But I suspect a lot of the appeal is simply that you can yell.
在瓦格赫，在那个让巴基斯坦作为国家存在的巨大线上的那一点，你至少可以带着凶猛感大喊大叫。也许这是一种展示你对巴基斯坦热爱的方式。但我怀疑大部分吸引力仅仅是因为你可以大喊大叫。
Mariya Karimjee.
Mariya Karimjee。
Act Four, "We Keep the Wall Between Us As We Go."
第四幕，“我们走的时候保持墙在我们之间”。
The very first official border wall between the United States and Mexico was actually just a fence in 1918 on the border between two cities with the same name, Nogales, Mexico, and Nogales, Arizona. Since then, the US has installed a much bigger fence-- thick, rust-colored steel rods. And every day at that spot at the border in Nogales, white buses from Homeland Security roll up full of people with deportation orders who are sent across the border into Mexico from the United States.
美国和墨西哥之间的第一道官方边境墙实际上只是1918年边境两个同名城市——墨西哥诺加莱斯和亚利桑那州诺加莱斯——之间的一道围栏。从那时起，美国安装了一道大得多的围栏——粗壮、铁锈色的钢杆。每天在诺加莱斯边境的那个地点，国土安全部的白色公交车会载满带着驱逐令的人，他们从美国被送往墨西哥。
Lots of them are parents with kids who are still in the States. They then just take up residence right on the other side of the wall. There's no official estimate of how many. It's probably in the thousands. And one of the saddest premises for a community that you can imagine-- all these parents separated from their own children, who are US citizens, who stay behind, sometimes with the parents' approval and best wishes, sometimes not. Reporter Lizzie Presser was curious about how these parents of kids remake their family lives around all this-- one family, in particular.
其中许多是孩子仍然留在美国的父母。他们然后就直接在墙的另一边住下来。没有关于有多少人的官方估计。可能成千上万。这是你能想象出的社区最悲伤的前提之一——所有这些与身为美国公民的孩子分离的父母，孩子留在了后面，有时得到了父母的批准和最美好的祝福，有时则不然。记者Lizzie Presser很好奇这些父母如何围绕所有这些重塑他们的家庭生活——特别是一个家庭。
Many of the parents who get dropped off don't exactly decide to stay on the Mexican side of Nogales. It's more that they never make the decision to leave. They have no friends or family here. Their original hometowns in Mexico are hundreds of miles away. But Nogales is the closest they can be to their kids, who aren't that far away in places like Arizona, Nevada, or Utah.
许多被送走的父母并没有完全决定留在墨西哥一侧的诺加莱斯。更多的是他们从未做出离开的决定。他们在这里没有朋友或家人。他们在墨西哥的原籍地在数百英里外。但诺加莱斯是他们能离孩子最近的地方，孩子在亚利桑那、内华达或犹他等地方并不远。
Local officials told me that this population of deported parents is a new one. They started showing up under President Obama. Their numbers picked up even more under President Trump.
当地官员告诉我，这群被驱逐的父母是一个新群体。他们在奥巴马总统任期内开始出现。特朗普总统任期内他们的人数甚至更多。
We hear about kids who get left behind in the States. But in Nogales, it's the parents who are orphaned. You can find these parents all over town. I met Emmanuel outside of a gym. He got deported two years ago.
我们听说孩子们被留在了美国。但在诺加莱斯，被孤立的是父母。你可以在整个城市找到这些父母。我在健身房外遇到了Emmanuel。他两年前被驱逐。
Why did you stick around?
你为什么留下来？
I'm here because I'm closer to my son. He's little, so he's two. He's barely walking. And I just don't want him to forget about me, you know?
我在这里是因为我离我儿子更近。他还小，才两岁。他刚刚会走路。我只是不想让他忘了我，你知道吗？
I then spotted this woman on the street wearing an Arizona Wildcats T-shirt and stopped her.
然后我在街上看到了这个穿着亚利桑那野猫队T恤的女人，拦住了她。
I'm working on a story on parents who have been deported to Nogales.
我正在写一个关于被驱逐到诺加莱斯的父母的故事。
Yeah, that's me, exactly me. So I got deported a year ago.
是的，那是我，正是我。所以我一年前被驱逐了。
This is Griselda Espinoza. Her kids are in Mesa, Arizona.
这位是Griselda Espinoza。她的孩子在亚利桑那州梅萨。
How many kids do you have?
你有几个孩子？
Three.
三个。
And how old are they?
他们多大了？
18, 16, and 6. It's hard, because I'm missing a lot of things.
18岁，16岁和6岁。这很难，因为我错过了很多事情。
Are there are certain times of the day that you miss your kids most?
一天中有什么时候你最想念你的孩子吗？
At night. At night, when I see their pictures. My son just won homecoming, and I wasn't there.
在晚上。在晚上，当我看到他们的照片时。我儿子刚刚赢得了返校节，而我没在那里。
She scrolls through her kids' Facebook pages every night before bed. I talked to another mom who said she sometimes spends hours on Google Earth tracing the streets in her old neighborhood in Phoenix.
她每天晚上睡前都会滚动浏览她孩子的Facebook页面。我和另一位妈妈谈过，她说她有时花几个小时在谷歌地球上追踪她在凤凰城老社区的街道。
I met parents all over the city. They work all day in factories and call centers and then come home to rooms they've decorated for their kids, who aren't there. One dad with a two-year-old still in Phoenix told me he installed a TV in his son's room, decked it out with Tonka trucks and Hot Wheels. When friends come over, he shuts the door to keep the room clean.
我在全市遇到了父母。他们整天在工厂和呼叫中心工作，然后回到他们为不在这里的孩子们装饰的房间。一位儿子仍在凤凰城的父亲告诉我，他给儿子的房间安装了一台电视，放满了Tonka卡车和风火轮玩具。当朋友来访时，他关上门以保持房间整洁。
But when I asked him the last time his son came to visit, he said it was more than a year ago. Sometimes, it's a really long wait for kids to cross over from the States. The mom I spent the most time with is Gloria Marin.
但当我问他儿子上次来看他是什么时候，他说那是超过一年前了。有时，孩子们从美国过来需要等待很长时间。我花最多时间相处的妈妈是Gloria Marin。
You need to cook the chili colorado?
你需要煮辣牛肉吗？
This is her early one morning last fall. She talked to her kids on the phone, and it sounded like they were coming today. So Gloria was making her son Angel's favorite dish, chili colorado, a red sauce she mixed with beef and cactus.
这是去年秋天一个清晨的她。她和孩子们通了电话，听起来他们今天会过来。所以Gloria在做她儿子Angel最喜欢的菜，辣牛肉，一种她混合了牛肉和仙人掌的红酱。
I've known Gloria and her family for a year and gotten close to them. She used to live in Phoenix with her four kids. She raised them there as a single mom. Now she lives in a small room behind a friend's house. She keeps a couple extra beds propped up against her wall and got a chihuahua for her daughters. Like a lot of the other deported parents in town, she always wants to be ready for her kids.
我认识Gloria和她的家人一年了，和他们很亲近。她以前在凤凰城带着四个孩子。她作为一个单身妈妈在那里抚养他们。现在她住在一个朋友家后面的小房间里。她把几张额外的床靠墙竖着，并为她的女儿买了一只吉娃娃。像城里其他被驱逐的父母一样，她总是想为孩子们做好准备。
Gloria has been in Nogales for more than five years. She's short with wavy black hair. She's quiet and kind of wistful when she talks. She wasn't expecting her kids until lunch, but she woke up at 5:00 AM to get ready. She wanted to look nice.
Gloria在诺加莱斯待了五年多了。她个子不高，留着波浪状的黑发。她很安静，谈话时带有一种怀旧感。她没指望孩子们午饭前能到，但她5点就起床准备了。她想看起来漂亮点。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Gloria's saying, I showered. I got dressed. I brushed my hair. I cleaned the house. I made the food.
Gloria说，我洗了澡。我穿好了衣服。我梳了头。我打扫了房子。我做了饭。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And I wait for them.
然后我等他们。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
That's all.
就是这样。
Gloria and her kids spent all their time together when they were in Phoenix. They did Friday movie nights, took camping trips, sold toys together at a swap meet on the weekends to make extra money. And then one day back in 2010, Gloria got arrested while her kids were at school.
Gloria和她的孩子们在凤凰城时总是待在一起。他们做周五电影夜，去露营，周末在跳蚤市场一起卖玩具赚外快。然后2010年的某一天，Gloria在孩子们上学时被捕了。
She'd been working as a housekeeper for a couple months when her boss got charged with running drop houses, places where undocumented immigrants spend the night after crossing the border. The prosecutors charged Gloria as an accomplice. She says she knew nothing about her boss's work, but she spent two years in prison. And then, since she wasn't documented, she was deported.
她当管家才几个月，她的老板就被指控经营中转站，即无证移民越境后过夜的地方。检察官指控Gloria是共犯。她说她对老板的工作一无所知，但她在监狱里待了两年。然后，由于她没有证件，她被驱逐了。
During that time, her kids lives started to unravel. The youngest was seven and the oldest 15. Her kids were split up and put into foster care. They could rarely talk to their mom or to each other.
在那段时间里，她孩子们的生活开始解体。最小的7岁，最大的15岁。她的孩子被分开送进寄养家庭。他们很少能和妈妈或彼此交谈。
Gloria spent her first year in Nogales trying to regain custody of her kids. But by the time she could convince Arizona's family court, only Gloria's youngest, who was 10, ended up joining her for a little. The others had been through hell, and they felt estranged from their mom.
Gloria在诺加莱斯的第一年都在试图重获孩子的监护权。但当她最终能说服亚利桑那州的家庭法院时，只有Gloria最小的、10岁的孩子来和她住了一小会儿。其他人经历了地狱般的日子，他们感到与妈妈疏远了。
It had been three years since they all lived together. Also, they didn't know Mexico, and they were scared to move there. They were US citizens whose lives were in Phoenix, three hours away.
距离他们住在一起已经三年了。而且，他们不知道墨西哥，害怕搬到那里。他们是生活在三小时车程外凤凰城的美国公民。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Gloria told me, when I was young and my kids were little, I thought that I could never live without them. I never thought that one day they'd grow up, and I'd be far away from them.
Gloria告诉我，我年轻时孩子们很小时，我以为我没有他们活不下去。我从没想过有一天他们会长大，而我会远离他们。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But you have to learn how to live like this.
但你必须学会如何这样生活。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's like a hope. It's the hope that any moment they'll say, Mom, I'm going over. And I'll be here waiting for them.
这就像一个希望。这个希望是任何时候他们都会说，妈妈，我要过去了。我会在这里等着他们。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I'm always just sitting around nervously, just waiting. I always await their visits thinking that, at any minute, they'll come.
我总是紧张地坐着，只是在等。我总是等待他们的访问，想着，任何时候，他们都会来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But they never really plan anything.
但他们从不真正计划任何事情。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Today, they said they'd visit. But what Gloria didn't know was that they weren't planning on coming across the border to her house and eating her chili colorado. They only wanted to come as far as the wall. There's a small visitor's section where the wall is just a mesh fence where people from the two sides go to talk.
今天，他们说他们会来访。但Gloria不知道的是，他们没打算越过边境去她的家吃她的辣牛肉。他们只想走到墙边。有一个小游客区，墙只是一道网格栅栏，双方的人去那里谈话。
I want to stay on this side.
我想留在这边。
This is Gloria's daughter, Yesi. She's 22, and she's bringing her two young children, one of whom has never met Gloria. And she just couldn't bring herself to tell her mom that she doesn't want to cross over into Mexico today.
这是Gloria的女儿Yesi。她22岁，带着两个年幼的孩子，其中一个从未见过Gloria。她只是无法让自己告诉妈妈，她今天不想越过墨西哥去她家。
No, if my mom hears that, she's going to be sad. She's going to think there's something wrong with her. I just make up excuses. I don't know what's wrong with me-- like excuse after excuse.
不，如果我妈妈听到了，她会难过的。她会以为她自己有什么问题。我只是编造借口。我不知道我怎么了——比如借口一个接一个。
Then why are you making up those excuses there?
那你为什么要在那儿编造这些借口？
I get super depressed not being able to be with her.
我超级沮丧，因为不能和她在一起。
She says it's really painful to see her mom. Gloria's house is a plywood shed, and she's working at a factory making $15 a day. Her health isn't great. She has diabetes.
她说看到妈妈真的很难受。Gloria的家是一个胶合板棚屋，她在工厂打工一天赚15美元。她的健康状况不佳。她有糖尿病。
Sometimes, she starts crying. And Yesi feels like there's nothing she can do to help her situation. It messes her up to see her mom that way.
有时，她开始哭。Yesi觉得她无能为力来改善现状。看到妈妈那样让她很受打击。
I don't think she understands the effect of us seeing her like that. She always calls me and tells me like, why are you ignoring me? I'm your mother. You need to see me. You need to talk to me. I want to cook for you. She tells me all these things.
我觉得她不明白我们看到她那样的影响。她总是打电话给我告诉我，比如，为什么你无视我？我是你的母亲。你需要见我。你需要和我谈话。我想为你做饭。她告诉了我所有这些事情。
Then what do you say?
那你怎么说？
I just tell her, oh, it's because I'm busy here. I've got stuff to do. But I don't do anything. I'm just here in my room.
我只是告诉她，哦，那是因为我这儿很忙。我有很多事要做。但我什么也没做。我只是在我的房间里。
When was the last time you saw your mom?
你上次见你妈妈是什么时候？
I can't even remember. I think it was December of last year. Yeah, it's been that long.
我甚至不记得了。我想是去年十二月。是的，已经那么久了。
And that was at the wall. Yesi hasn't crossed over to visit her mother's house since 2014. It's not that she doesn't love her mom. They talk on the phone, text, send each other cute emojis.
那是在墙边。Yesi自2014年以来就没越境去过她母亲家。并不是说她不爱她妈妈。她们在电话上谈话，发短信，互发可爱的表情符号。
But in the past, when Yesi's gone to see her mom, she's left her ID at home on purpose then told her mom it was an accident. That way, crossing wasn't an option. She could only meet Gloria at the wall and talk there. She wouldn't have to see her at her house. It just wasn't as intense. The wall is helpful for Yesi. It helps her keep some emotional distance.
但在过去，当Yesi去见她妈妈时，她故意把身份证留在了家里，然后告诉她妈妈那是个意外。这样，越境就不是一个选择了。她只能在墙边见Gloria并谈话。她不必在家里见她。那没那么强烈。墙对Yesi很有帮助。它帮助她保持了一些情感距离。
Staying on the US side of the wall helps Yesi in another way. The last time she crossed over to visit Gloria in her home, four years ago, she'd only planned to visit for a few days. But she almost didn't come back. She ended up living there for four months with her daughter, who was just a toddler.
留在墙的美国一侧也以另一种方式帮助了Yesi。四年前她上次越境去她在家里见Gloria时，她只计划待几天。但她差点就没能回来。她最终和她刚会走路的女儿在那里住了四个月。
She hadn't felt that comfortable in years. She and Gloria talked about how Yesi could get a job on the US side of the border, commute there during the day, and then stay in Mexico with Gloria at night. And for months, Yesi let herself believe it was possible.
她多年来没感到那么舒服了。她和Gloria谈到Yesi如何能在边境的美国一侧找份工作，白天在那里通勤，晚上和Gloria一起留在墨西哥。几个月来，Yesi让自己相信这是可能的。
But then her real life caught up with her. She couldn't keep putting off school, her kids' dad, who was in Arizona. She had too many responsibilities. And ever since, seeing her mom just reminded her of what she couldn't have.
但随后她真正的生活赶上了她。她不能再推迟学校了，还有在亚利桑那的孩子们的爸爸。她有太多责任了。从那以后，见妈妈只是提醒她无法拥有什么。
You're nervous that if you go, you won't come back.
你很紧张，如果你去了，你就回不来了。
Yeah, because that's what I want. I just want to be with her. I guess I have no self-control. Ugh. That's why I don't like going over there.
是的，因为那是我想要的。我只想和她在一起。我想我没有自控力。啊。这就是我不喜欢去那边的原因。
But have you ever thought about just saying to her, like, it's hard for me to come because I miss you too much?
但你有没有想过只是对她说，比如，我很难过来，因为我太想你了？
How do you tell the person that you love the most in this world, I don't want to see you because I come home, and I'm not the same because of you? You don't want to tell her that.
你怎么告诉在这个世界上你最爱的人，我不想见你是因为我回家了，我因为你而变得不像我自己了？你不想告诉她。
Her little brother, Angel, is also ambivalent about seeing their mom. And today, he plans to stay on the US side of the fence with Yesi.
她弟弟Angel对见妈妈也持矛盾态度。今天，他计划和Yesi留在栅栏的美国一侧。
I get butterflies because I feel nervous. It's like I'm meeting a whole different person, even though I know her. I don't know. I just sometimes feel like I'm a stranger to her. And sometimes, she's a stranger to me.
我感到蝴蝶乱飞，因为我感到紧张。就像我遇到了一个完全不同的人，即使我认识她。我不知道。我只是有时觉得我是她的陌生人。有时，她是我的陌生人。
Angel's 18 now. He was 10 when Gloria was picked up. And in those eight years, Gloria has changed a lot. In prison, Gloria became really religious. Now she goes to mass three times each week, and she's always talking to Angel and Yesi about God, reading them passages from the Bible.
Angel现在18岁。Gloria被抓时他10岁。在那八年里，Gloria改变了很多。在监狱里，Gloria变得非常虔诚。现在她每周去三次弥撒，总是和Angel及Yesi谈论上帝，给他们读圣经段落。
She used to stroll into school to pick them up in ripped Guess jeans and a big perm. At home, she'd blast Madonna and Michael Jackson while they cleaned the house together. Now she wears long dresses and "church lady" shoes. She's reserved.
她以前穿着破洞的Guess牛仔裤和夸张的卷发去接他们放学。在家时，她会播放麦当娜和迈克尔·杰克逊的歌，同时他们一起打扫房子。现在她穿着长裙和“教会女士”鞋。她很矜持。
Angel's kind of a goof, and he used to crack his mom up all the time. But now, he says, she's lost her sense of humor. He feels like he can't be himself around her.
Angel是个有点傻的人，他以前总是让妈妈开怀大笑。但现在，他说，她失去了幽默感。他觉得在妈妈面前他无法做回自己。
I'll make fun of people, just be like, yo, that guy gots a bald head. You can see your future. And it's like a magic ball. And she'll be like, don't make fun of that person, you know? They have issues too.
我会嘲笑别人，比如，嘿，那家伙头秃了。你可以看到你的未来。那就像个魔法球。她会说，不要嘲笑那个人，你知道吗？他们也有麻烦。
I'll be like, Mom, I'm just trying to make you laugh, but OK. If you're just going to continue to be like that with me, then why should we even speak? Because I don't want to feel that vibe with my own mother.
我会说，妈妈，我只是想让你笑，但好吧。如果你只是要继续那样对我，那我们为什么还要说话？因为我不想和自己的母亲那种氛围。
Do you feel like she used to appreciate this part of you?
你觉得她过去欣赏你的这一部分吗？
I think so, yeah, shoot.
我想是的，是的，天哪。
Angel and Yesi both can't let go of the way their mom used to be back in Phoenix. Yesi wants her to act more like a mom, to fake that she's happy even when she's not, to tell her what to do.
Angel和Yesi都无法放下妈妈在凤凰城时的样子。Yesi想让她表现得更像个妈妈，即使在不高兴时也假装开心，告诉她该做什么。
Of course, they have practical reasons for not visiting. They don't have much money for bus tickets. Yesi's kids need her attention. It's easy to blame it on that stuff and not talk about the rest of it, though it's hard not to feel guilty.
当然，他们不探望有实际原因。他们没有多少钱买巴士票。Yesi的孩子需要她的关注。很容易把原因归咎于这些事情，而不是谈论剩下的部分，尽管很难不感到内疚。
Sometimes, I feel like my mom feels that we don't love her.
有时，我觉得我妈妈觉得我们不爱她。
Do you feel like your love for your mom now is the same as it was before she left?
你觉得你现在对妈妈的爱和你离开前一样吗？
I really don't know what it is right now. [LAUGHS] When my mom, she tells me she loves me, I'll tell her, I love you too, Mom.
我真的不知道现在是什么。[笑] 当我妈妈，她告诉我她爱我，我会告诉她，我也爱你，妈妈。
And what do you feel?
那你感觉到了什么？
Nothing.
什么都没有。
Is that scary?
这很可怕吗？
No, it's just a feeling that you feel, like when you're just too deep into something that you just can't get out of, or you feel you can't get out of.
不，这只是一种感觉，就像当你深陷某事而无法脱身时，或者你觉得你无法脱身。
Angel's not completely disconnected from Gloria though. He's discovered that she has a very specific physical effect on him that no one else has. After Gloria was arrested, Angel stopped being able to sleep through the night. But when he visited her at her home in Nogales for the first time, Gloria lay down next to him. At the time, he was just 14.
Angel并没有完全与Gloria断开联系。他发现她对他有一种特殊的物理影响，没有人有。Gloria被捕后，Angel晚上无法入睡。但当他第一次在诺加莱斯的家里见她时，Gloria躺在他身边。当时他才14岁。
I instantly fell asleep because she was rubbing my head. I just knocked out quick.
我立刻睡着了，因为她在摸我的头。我很快就睡着了。
Had you not had that since she'd been arrested?
她在被捕后你没过那个吗？
Yeah. That was like the best, decent sleep. Like, I would compare it to the last time I was like in the fetus, bro, like just chilling, just going-- just sleeping, you know? I had no thoughts, no negative thoughts. I didn't have to worry about bills, no nothing.
是的。那是最体面的睡眠。比如，我会把它比作我最后一次像在胎儿里一样，兄弟，就像只是放松，只是走——只是睡觉，你知道吗？我没有任何想法，没有任何负面想法。我不必担心账单，什么都不必担心。
Sounds like very good sleep to me.
听起来是非常好的睡眠。
Do you ask them to visit more often?
你让他们更经常来访吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Gloria told me, yes, but I don't know.
Gloria告诉我，是的，但我不知道。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Maybe because of time and money, I don't know.
也许因为时间和钱，我不知道。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
They can't come so much. I don't know.
他们不能经常来。我不知道。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So I never thought that this would happen, that they'd make the decision to not come.
所以我从没想过会发生这种情况，他们会决定不来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Before, I used to get angry because they didn't come. And I used to ask myself why, ask myself if they'd lost their love for their mom and all that.
以前，我经常因为他们不来而生气。我经常问自己为什么，问自己他们是否失去了对妈妈的爱等等。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But now, I just want them to feel good so that they want to come again.
但现在，我只是想让他们感觉良好，这样他们就想再来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So these days, that's Gloria's entire strategy. She tries to play it cool when she's on the phone with them. She doesn't want to sound needy or talk about how hard things are for her.
所以这些天来，这就是Gloria的整个策略。她在电话里和他们聊天时试图装作淡定。她不想显得需要帮助或谈论她有多困难。
In the morning, back in Phoenix, Yesi put on full makeup. Brisa, the youngest kid, braided Angel's hair. The three of them packed into the car around 7:00 AM with Yesi's kids and headed south to stand on the Arizona side of the border and talk to their mom through a fence.
早上，回到凤凰城，Yesi化了全妆。Brisa，最小的孩子，给Angel辫了头发。三个人七点左右带上Yesi的孩子塞进车里，向南去站在边境的亚利桑那侧，通过栅栏和妈妈谈话。
In Nogales, Gloria finished cooking and then sat on her bed, watching the clock, still unaware that her kids weren't planning to cross over. When it hit 10:00 AM, Gloria left her house, got in her car, and started driving to the border to pick them up, 10 minutes away.
在诺加莱斯，Gloria做完饭然后坐在床上看着时钟，仍然不知道她的孩子没打算越境。当时间到了10点，Gloria离开房子，上车，开始开车前往边境接他们，10分钟远。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Suddenly, her cell phone rang.
突然，她的手机响了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It was her kids.
是她的孩子。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Gloria's saying, are you guys coming?
Gloria说，你们来了吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Wait, you're there? I'm on my way.
等等，你们在那里？我在路上。
OK, mijo, I love you.
好的，孩子，我爱你。
Her kids had all crossed. I don't think it was because I was with them recording. They'd had a massive change of heart. Brisa, the youngest, had been telling her siblings that Gloria was doing fine, and they needed to chill out and stop making such a big deal out of visiting her house.
她的孩子都过了边境。我不认为是因为我录音才这样。他们彻底改变了心意。Brisa，最小的孩子，一直告诉她的兄弟姐妹Gloria过得很好，他们需要冷静下来，别再把访问她的房子当回事了。
And so when they got to the border, the siblings didn't talk about it. Nobody said anything. Angel looked down and saw his feet walking across the border. They pushed through a metal gate. Suddenly, they were in Mexico. Gloria pulled up and honked.
所以当他们到达边境时，兄弟姐妹没谈论它。没人说什么。Angel低头看着他的脚穿过边境。他们推开一扇金属门。突然，他们在墨西哥了。Gloria开车过来按了喇叭。
Yesi, it's your first time here in three years.
Yesi，这是你三年来第一次到这里。
I know. It's been a while.
我知道。已经很久了。
Yesi went to hug her. She told her mom that her hair smelled good. Everyone kissed each other and piled into the car.
Yesi去拥抱她。她告诉她妈妈她的头发味道很好。每个人都吻了对方并涌入车里。
At Gloria's house, the kids immediately sat down to start eating. They only had an hour. Angel had to get back to Phoenix for work that night.
在Gloria家，孩子立刻坐下来开始吃。他们只有一个小时。Angel那天晚上必须回凤凰城工作。
For all their talk about their hang ups with their mom, they got casual really fast. Yesi's bodysuit was bothering her, so she unsnapped it and let the flaps hang loose. Angel was trying to learn how to say "burp" in Spanish.
尽管他们谈论过对妈妈的各种纠结，他们很快就放松了下来。Yesi的连体衣让她不舒服，所以她解开扣子让襟片下垂。Angel正在试图学习如何用西班牙语说“打嗝”。
Is it "eructa" or "erupta?"
是“eructa”还是“erupta”？
Eructa.
Eructa。
Gloria wasn't eating. She was just watching them. She had this dreamy smile on her face. This was the first time they'd all sat around a table together since 2010.
Gloria没在吃。她只是看着他们。她脸上带着梦幻般的微笑。这是他们自2010年以来第一次坐在一起吃饭。
After lunch, they all climbed into Gloria's bed, insisting they had food comas. But really, they just wanted an excuse to cuddle with their mom. Angel curled up. He's about 5 feet, 90 pounds. He'd insisted on wearing a baggy sweatshirt that day so he didn't look too skinny. Gloria started rubbing his head. It was like a magic trick.
午饭后，他们都爬进Gloria的床上，坚持说他们吃撑了。但其实，他们只是想找借口和妈妈依偎。Angel蜷缩起来。他大约5英尺，90磅。他那天坚持穿了一件宽松的运动衫，这样他看起来不那么瘦。Gloria开始摸他的头。那就像个魔法戏法。
When my mom rubs my head and I'm sleeping, it's already over.
当我妈妈摸我的头而我在睡觉时，一切就结束了。
Angel closed his eyes, and then it was time to leave. Yesi and her kids stayed behind with Gloria, but just for three extra days this time. They talked again about living together in Mexico.
Angel闭上眼睛，然后到了离开的时候。Yesi和她的孩子留在了Gloria身边，但这次只是多留了三天。她们再次谈论在墨西哥生活在一起。
Yesi told her she'd move down there in a month or so. She'd buy Gloria a plot of land with a small house, just big enough for the whole family. Yesi told me it made them both happy, just saying all those things, even though she knew and her mom knew that it wasn't going to happen. And for the first time, that was OK.
Yesi告诉她一个月左右她就会搬过来。她会给Gloria买一块地带一个小房子，刚好够全家人住。Yesi告诉我，光是说这些话就让她们俩都很开心，尽管她知道，她妈妈也知道，这不会发生。而第一次，那没关系。
Lizzie Presser. To help report this story, Lizzie got a grant from the International Women's Media Foundation as an Adelante Fellow. She was also supported by the Investigative Fund at The Nation Institute
Lizzie Presser。为了帮助报道这个故事，Lizzie从国际妇女媒体基金会获得了Adelante Fellow的资助。她还得到了国家研究所调查基金的支持。
[MUSIC - "WHEN THE WALLS CAME DOWN" BY THE CALL]
[音乐 - The Call演唱的“WHEN THE WALLS CAME DOWN”]
(SINGING) Well, they blew the horns, and the walls came down. They'd all been warned, and the walls came down. They stood there laughing. They're not laughing anymore. The walls came down.
（演唱）好吧，他们吹响了号角，围墙倒塌了。他们都被警告过，围墙倒塌了。他们站在那里笑着。他们不再笑了。围墙倒塌了。
Our program was produced today by David Kestenbaum and Louise Sullivan. The people who put our show together includes Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Michelle Harris, Kimberly Henderson, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton. Production help from Anna Martin and Stone Nelson.
我们节目今天由David Kestenbaum和Louise Sullivan制作。制作我们节目的人包括Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Michelle Harris, Kimberly Henderson, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney和Diane Wu。我们的高级制作人是Brian Reed。我们的主编是Susan Burton。Anna Martin和Stone Nelson协助制作。
Special thanks today to Robert Frost, to California Sunday Magazine, The Kino Border Initiative, Carmen Noriega, Catalina Maria Johnston, Vicky Cosstick, Peter Curran, Mark Gordon, Zeynep Bilginsoy, Matt Alesevich, Zach Campbell, James Hathaway, Rebecca Hamlin, Jesus Blasco de Avellaneda, Nick Fountain, Nate Rott, Charles Maynes, Frankie Quinn, Brahim B. Ali. Interpreting today by Daniel Sherr.
今天特别感谢Robert Frost，加州周日杂志，Kino边境倡议，Carmen Noriega, Catalina Maria Johnston, Vicky Cosstick, Peter Curran, Mark Gordon, Zeynep Bilginsoy, Matt Alesevich, Zach Campbell, James Hathaway, Rebecca Hamlin, Jesus Blasco de Avellaneda, Nick Fountain, Nate Rott, Charles Maynes, Frankie Quinn, Brahim B. Ali。今天由Daniel Sherr提供口译。
Our website, where this week we have this incredible interactive map where you can fly around to see all the walls in today's stories all over the globe, created by International Mapping. See that at thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio station by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，本周我们有这个令人难以置信的互动地图，你可以飞越查看今天故事中全球所有的墙，由International Mapping创建。请在thisamericanlife.org查看。《这就是美国生活》由公共广播交换中心PRX发送给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he just showed us our new office plan. We are all moving into cubicles-- very, very tiny cubicles. He likes them small.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他刚向我们展示了我们的新办公室规划。我们都将搬进小隔间——非常非常小的小隔间。他喜欢小的。
I would compare it to the last time I was in the fetus, bro, like just chilling.
我会把它比作我最后一次像在胎儿里一样，兄弟，就像只是放松。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周回来，带来更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "WHEN THE WALLS CAME DOWN" BY THE CALL]
[音乐 - The Call演唱的“WHEN THE WALLS CAME DOWN”]